hello everybody i'm done okay wait i know i'm missing something here give me a sec poof abercadabra all right give me a sec i realize i i am missing oh wait why did i disappear i can i have a steam deck i
but I'm not okay there after after hot pot I went straight to bed and then I like message my man just like make my waiting room I sleep I'm in food coma and then I guess like I forgot to specify like what the title should be or like You know, like what is the title and like the context of what the thing by the way I just found out I thought this was gonna be a team game This is I thought we are doing a team Seeker game because there were two secret teams.
So I should have asked tempo The details about is this individual seeker games or This is an individual seeker kill race.
So this is not gonna be a race.
It's gonna be a walk I mean, I default immediately to Rape, like normal, but we can play something else.
Well, it's a competition, so.
Yeah, it's a competition.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a, I mean, we're seeking though, right?
Yeah, we're seeking.
Yeah, but we're individual kill race right now.
I know all the rules, obviously.
Yeah, exactly.
I don't know what's happening here.
Yeah, no, I just found out it's individual.
I thought it was team because there's two secret teams.
I literally was like team secret going crazy.
it's not that's not no no no don't worry it's mostly going to be you two are going to fight each other for this race i'm just going to scroll stroll around the park so our biggest thing is um we can't use recon legend no no you can't we have going on and everything else is but they can so they can be ripping like valkyrie bro just flying up yeah zoom in everywhere that's true yeah that's what i'm saying like they're probably ripping valk which makes me absolutely concerned yeah are you gonna are you gonna like follow haste and rip bulk too are you gonna play no we can't play because she's recon bro you're so again i know exactly what's going on at all times obviously i'm very tapped in right now i'm very locked you're very like yo is gino with you right now is he like standing behind you like monitoring no no he's not standing behind but he is okay so my not teammates in the office is that i'm in right now uh drum drum bud is like at the Nokia facility right now.
That's why we're like, how are you not locked in?
You were like literally at there.
Sorry, my bad.
Okay, so what are each of us playing so we don't accidentally steal someone's character?
I'm not.
I think because it's a competition between us, like I think it's just you go.
Whoever gets it first.
Bro, I'm just, bro, I'm not even competition.
Don't do this to me.
I'm not even.
i'm not even i just want you guys to know i have not booted up apex in a while so that's okay all you're doing is shooting people and hunting them down they can't yeah this is the thing they can't shoot you back right but you could also be playing us right now you could be like low-key yeah this could be a lot you could be uncle filling us on the pool table oh sure sure i could just be like gaslighting all of you and i have like a secret weapon i'm she's about to break out lucille and now i'm cooked guys like i'm trying to give you guys very low expectations like in blindside all of you and then you're gonna see like 80 kills from me i don't know where i got the extra 40 from but i'm gonna kill 80 players spawn farming yeah yeah i'm respawn farming too just to prove a point 80 is 80 is that's i'm now i'm scared i wasn't scared before you that's right now i'm terrified also i'm very surprised nice wig is like alive right now because he had he did a japanese tournament like a couple of
hours ago so oh he's cooked he's yeah he might be hiding spots yeah i thought he was just casting apparently he's going straight in right after i don't know if i can kill wig that's all that matters all right i'm gonna see if i could pick guys what should i pick guys maybe i'll get first pick should i do like path five which is i don't know guys like i said i haven't like touched apex in a while just because i had a lot of other stuff going on so i will say um the next three games though after we're done seeking we are a team again yeah we are a team in hiding and that's what i'm looking forward to more than anything if we work together now you know to tell me what you might may or may not not throw in hiders see i like yeah but who's who's listen if we become a team who's gonna get the 25k for charity is it do you not remember it's for charity no i know i wanted to go to my charity i wanted to go to my local shelter it's shouldn't be like no matter who wins a chair like charity wins
no matter who wins there's a winner that's the best one yeah you don't care about the cancer research that i want to pick you don't care about cancer is that it yeah no i no i do no don't yeah all right stop stop stop you don't want my cancer charity to win that's messed up that's I want my charity to win.
I want everybody's charity to win, but there can only be one winner for the charity.
That's messed up.
Temples should just give us all win.
Temples just change the rules and make this a team thing.
That's what I was used to me.
There's no other rules for us, right, as seekers.
No, no.
It's literally whoever gets the most kills.
Say less.
Yeah, so anyway, guys, like I said, please don't.
please don't judge me because please because it's guys what guns are strong i should ask that actually oh my god i i would aim them first person in so long i was like my manager is like you should put up apex just to practice but then i had like the street fighting thing and then i had all the other stuff going on so i'm just like oh no i should have put it this game and actually I'd even go to the training training room I just went like the practice range I just went straight into this custom lobby
oh my god like I was so tired do not perceive me chat everyone's gonna run around and then they're cut to me and they're like Jokey Bird was zero killings.
And I'm like, stop!
Stop!
Stop, don't put me on the screen!
You're gonna watch like 20 people run away from me and I'm like, please don't do this.
But yeah, I'm doing that.
Guys, I was playing a fighting game the last week, guys.
My hands are not aiming today.
don't you 100% watch guys what do you mean of course I have I I obsess over one game and then I move on to the next like it's always been like this for the end of time I obsess over one game and then move to the next like my brain has no capacity for more than one game at a time oh my god yeah i was punched out using my fists guys what if okay what if i like mess with people and just start punching people and then they'll be like whoa whoa whoa bro i'm tired i am i like passed out and i woke up at 10 a.m yeah shh we don't talk about rivals guys i can't talk about it like not in front of the not in front of not in front of nokia not in front of nokia guys anyway huge shout out to tempo for uh for inviting me to this tournament i was like bro you're hosting a hat and see can i join and you want to be seekers and i assume it was a team thing i was like sure buddy and but yeah it's for the wi-fi um it's for like uh remember the last nokia hodansi tournament i joined um yeah but we have a
solution for this head but then you need a super chat miracle thank you thank you uh meganami welcome to tomato farm welcome welcome um yeah i'm on wi-fi of course um anyway guys uh i don't know what to expect uh today guys i i don't know i i don't know what to expect because uh i guess we have i don't know i thought it was a team thing now that i know that um it's all reliant on me and me only,
I'm scared.
Because I was like, no matter what happens, my team's got my back.
And then I realized the team is only me.
And I know I do not got my back.
I do not.
Me, myself, and I, I don't have my own back, guys.
Guys, my team is terrible.
And the team is only me.
But...
Uh, we're only doing, we're doing like three, three games, three games as seekers.
And then after that, we're doing, we're going to be, uh, we're going to be hiders after that.
So at least I have a team by then.
Yeah.
A team is 100% throwing.
We're just missing two people.
So, uh, yeah.
So we're just chilling.
We're chilling.
But I don't know.
It'll be fun no matter.
At least at that point, we're just going to enjoy the scenery.
It's just between a drum and moose.
This is going to be the hardest 1v1.
They think it's a...
They think there's three people in this competition.
How cute is that?
It's just a 1v1.
And then they cut to me.
And I'm just...
La la la.
I just hope I hope they don't notice the zero kills I I'll get my kills at the very end when the circle is closing and then I'll be like they're like oh my god don't keep it finally got a kill when everyone's just bunched up in the tiny ass zone I'm like yay
I'll wait until that I'll wait until the cat we're hurting the cattle guys when we hurt the cattle Then, then we will get our kills.
Yeah, I play the long game.
They're going to run out of ammo when it's end zone.
But I'll have all the ammo.
I'll have all the ammo for end zone.
Because they'll be too busy shooting air while chasing people.
I know.
to go down oh i'm first pick i think it's freaking time no you're not first no i'm first pick i can feel it i see it it's already here i can i have i have an in with gino i have an in with gino so oh my god no no no of course i'm the last oh wait actually i'm literally playing that character anyway i don't know i gotta play my own native most comfortable all right see on the other or no i i guess we can we could probably probably talk yeah yeah i can't imagine like a world where we're not allowed to talk we just give like false information we'll be like oh my god i saw someone heading over there yeah true i'm just gonna feed lies and nonsense i can do nothing but spread misinformation that's what i'm best at oh wait i don't need oh when did i get top ranking matt yeah we are the secret so all right we are do we just wait we just wait right well we wait What do you have to do,
like, look up or something, or...
I don't know.
I'm trying to look at it.
No, no, we can look.
But they're just gonna be running around anyway.
No, I'm not even gonna look.
No, I'm gonna win without looking.
I'm literally not even looking at the screen right now.
I'm staring at all of them.
I don't care.
Where the fuck is...
It's been a while, guys.
How crazy would it be if somebody landed at, like, Spotted Lake?
I'm good with that, dude.
There's no way.
Wow, who would ever think landing right beside us?
There's no one coming out of the...
Yeah, they're all on this side.
Yeah, the whole map's gonna be the other side of the map because everyone saw that we had to land it right off.
Alright, here we go.
Hey guys, I think I saw someone at Spotted Lake.
Who's gonna get that?
Who's gonna get that kill at Spotted Lake, guys?
Huge, massive comms.
I know exactly what I'm doing here.
play hey guys you just know what's better what's the current meta gun guys by the way what's the strongest oh that would be the p2020 singular by itself on the fourth yeah it has the p2020 no anything honestly at this point right now it's kind of anything you want it to be hey who stole that r9 what the hell oh who could that be god what a freak generally actually wasn't me that's the crazy part yeah and wasn't me either maybe a hide is next to us i i definitely didn't see ducky do it not at all nope nope I'm pretty I think I saw a hider like went behind you and took it Honestly,
that's a bar Y'all are cheating.
How are we cheating?
If anything is to hiders that's cheating I'm not I'm not going anywhere.
I might just like stick around.
Oh, you know, why you don't need early?
Yeah, and just grease your kills Oh, yeah, you should definitely do that.
I think I think that's that's my play i think that's my play i'm just gonna grease your kills buddy yeah don't mind me i'm nothing that you're a pathfinder i can't keep up with you i can keep up with the rain don't mind me i i'm not doing anything here i'm just chilling what do you mean i keep taking meds because i think we're playing a real game i know i literally have i have phoenix kit syringes we're allowed i don't know why i'm ripping batteries and shit I don't know why I'm being all I don't want to give you guys like perks but like I kind of got to get my my flu you know what I mean yeah we got to get our own perks I'm kind of being like an op right now against you guys listen it's a charity event you can yeah dude I don't I want to win I'm a charity that's messed up we're all winners each of us if any of us wins it goes to a good cause and you don't even want to help out a great cause yeah my cause is better than your cause whoa that's real crazy you know what though you hate
abandoned puppies dude you hate abandoned puppies oh and you hate cancer you hate cancer whoa yeah you don't want to fix it you don't want to sick kids that can't afford video games come on now oh all right i'm gonna go we're scanning beacons over here i mean uh not over here i got somebody on me you got someone on you oh i got someone on me too i uh not me no bullshit oh no wait can we not kill people yet come here buddy Where are you at?
Yeah, we can, but then this all fucking flew away from me.
I'm sick.
Woo!
Dude, focused audio.
I know.
Oh, he went through the freaking wall.
No, I was fucking with this guy.
I was like, wait, can I not shoot you yet?
I'm surprised you didn't choose Alter, dude.
Yeah, I might have been a mistake.
It's fine.
No, I was messing with this one guy and then he just ran away.
He doesn't know it's me, right?
Surely?
Surely this guy doesn't know that I'm a seeker.
Somebody's, like, gonna be up here, bro.
I don't think we're allowed to shoot yet.
What do you mean?
Oh, wait, is that real?
Yeah, we're not allowed to shoot yet.
Says who?
Says in the rules.
Did you guys not read the rules?
How long do I have to wait until the zone closes?
No.
I literally am about to kill a person right in front of me.
No, no.
You're waiting until you wait until the zone closes and then you shoot someone.
Ducky would never mislead me, right?
Of course not.
Why would I mislead you?
This is a team game.
Team effort?
I don't know what's going on.
Me either.
No, no, it's me.
You don't know me there.
That's true.
I didn't try to get it because he was, he and I were just chilling next to each other because we thought like, uh, we were like...
I'm literally just chasing this person in a circle right now, not killing me.
Yeah, you have to wait until the zone ends.
You did not know that?
No.
I can read.
Go check out the, go, bro, check out the rules right now.
Yeah, but let's check out the rules.
Yeah.
I'm going to do it right now.
Yeah, go do it right now.
All right.
Where is it?
I really need you to tell me because I've been chasing this altar for a year and a half.
Yeah, no, it's true.
I literally see somebody in front of me.
I'm just- I've been- I've been circling- Kill points.
Seekers will drop at the furthest point.
And that's it.
Wait, that's all it is.
That's all the tournament format.
It's in the- Did you not read?
It was in the tempo posted that for us.
Do you see the map?
I feel it.
All right, I mean, I'm just gonna wait the 40 seconds then.
I'm surely I'm getting baited, surely.
I feel like I'm getting baited too, but I'm just gonna wait 30 seconds anyway, just in case.
I can't even see the, oh yeah, I see it.
Is it when the ringing starts closing, we can do it?
Yeah.
Dude, I think she's lying, bro.
How am I lying?
I'm trying to make sure we don't get in trouble.
Dude, I think you're fucking lying.
How am I lying?
I think I'm gonna just land it on me and make sure you don't shoot them cuz we're not allowed to until five seconds I know where somebody is that's why I've been lurking when zone so much closing I can do it yeah yeah all right I'm killing this fool yep same three two one go by the way I was lying so I don't know why you believe me I could have been good for six years I could have been got this
I'm never trusting anything, anyone, any, ever again.
Trust is now gone.
Bro, that is, that is so evil.
I could be in the lead.
Don't be.
I'm actually sick.
No, you're, honestly, you're a genius.
No, you're a genius.
You're like, yeah, what can I say?
You guys did not kill for sat that long.
That's, that's, I literally got the ping.
I literally got the ping that you were freaking shooting.
someone and i was still like oh look but i still believe you like you should have read the rules that's crazy someone wasn't reading you're a mastermind you're a mastermind it's okay i didn't get zero what is going on the hiding team i'm literally i'm literally kicking you out of your spot and making you go bro you're kicking me out this is a team game we're not gonna win the charity i'm colluding now oh you don't even care about your own charity i guess listen as long is a charity get some love you know i'm saying bro i'm just here for the vibes bro i'm just i'm looking in every little corner oh wait here's somebody bro aren't you in the yeah aren't you in the nokia hq you could literally ask nokia that's a fact you could have actually just asked nokia like you're literally there that's your thing They're behind one door.
Dad, you're so fake for that.
You're the fakeest human, I think, ever.
What?
Me?
What did I do?
I'm just vibing, guys.
Come here, Revenant.
Raising Elijah's.
OK, I...
In progress.
That should be the goat player over here.
okay i did it for cancer research guys honestly valid but also like oh my god you guys are actually killing people i'm let's go damn hey guys i had 260 damage just casually shooting people wait why is there a death box oh wait they were don't worry guys i'm i'm pretty good at seeking right now damn some would say i'm him Okay,
I've been sort of gaslighting the hiders, so like not really playing the game.
No, that was different.
No, I'm not.
You guys are seeing, I've been also gaslighting the hiders as well.
But I've been like just running up to them, running with them.
Oh, well, that's a good strat.
You're kind of, you're kind of cooking with the shots.
Yeah, but the thing is, I'm not shooting them.
I'm just running next to them.
Make sure that nobody's up here, bro.
I'm just casually hanging out with them.
Hmm.
all right it's okay i'm just hanging out with my fellow hiders
hello fellow hiders how do you do you know what's nice i can see that i'm wait that's genius bro someone's in a crypto drone invisible somewhere around me oh don't get don't get too caught up in it buddy you're gonna waste some time let me get all the kills enhance my weapon wait someone res what yeah buddy just destroy the drone You thought I was one of you.
I'm not.
Hello, bro
Hey there, Valkyrie.
Don't you want to hang out with me?
No!
I'm stuck!
I don't understand why they all are scared of me.
I'm not doing anything.
Oh, hey, Moose.
My god, dude, it actually worked.
What?
Bro!
Thanks for that, Moose.
Appreciate it.
Oh my god, that is so dust.
Somebody threw a horizon ult at me and I couldn't hear.
Why are you so scared?
I'm not gonna lie.
Dude, that was so dust.
Bro, I couldn't hear it.
Draft, brother.
That one was money.
Oh yeah, what?
Contact with hostile broken air.
I'm never gonna be able to catch this guy.
I'm just chilling.
I only shoot.
One of the hottest shots tried to shoot me.
I got scared.
Oh my god.
Okay, that dude's gonna get away.
He's just gonna get away.
There's nothing I can do about it.
There he is.
Yeah, but they had.
Okay, so some of the hiders have guns on their back too, so...
Yeah, let me find out.
Oh my god.
What did I punch you?
I know.
Let's chill together.
I'm so pissed off that...
I'm so pissed off that you got that killed, bro, that actually teased me up.
That's a dub.
Oh, they're resting, they're resting, they're resting.
that I heard hey buddy whoa I'm not gonna lie horizons with the new glider is like the hardest of killing this right now they're just running yeah they're all just hanging out here little buddy oh this is easy this easy money right here This is easy money.
Down.
All right, bud.
I know we're not, I'm not winning this.
I'm gaslighting right now.
Well, I could participate in this race when I know I'm not even part of the race.
Oh, that Valkyrie's moving.
That Valkyrie's moving.
Bro, that almost worked on me.
worked on me.
It's a moose.
The moose got to be the killier right now.
Of course I am.
I hate your guts.
I'm coming for you though.
Please know that I'm coming for you.
Oh, this Valkholtz are nuts, bro.
Come here, buddy.
Bro, are we going to be best friends?
Wait, where's this Valk?
My best friend.
Dang, bro.
I'm still...
Okay, you might be cheating.
Guys, okay, you guys see a Valk next to me?
don't kill him i'm playing the long game with her honestly i respect that my god no oh no oh my god this bath is so loose i'm good for him it's probably caution lookie
yeah you think it's a man he is you think it's a striker you think it's a striker he's a freak you all got those things are on here brother oh it's man Dude, he's still jukeing me on the ground.
Bro, that guy's a freak.
I'm sorry.
He's a freak.
Die, Greek!
The one chill that meant it all.
I got Greek.
Oh my god.
They're all just malking away from me.
Oh.
What is this?
oh these guys are tripping no he's one and he can't get off oh I guarantee it oh God there's round three I guarantee you can't get off I may be wasting a lot of time oh this is about to be nuts this is gonna be nuts no please please please
Come here, Mr. Shiv.
Sorry, Mr. FPS.
You gotta go.
Hey, buddy.
Why would you pick up?
He had a Krayber.
He did?
He didn't want us to have the Krayber.
That's why.
Honestly, that's lucky smart.
Yeah, that's smart.
He's just...
What?
Whoa, guys.
We're doing it, everyone.
Bro.
This is they're just floating on these things.
I'm having fun, everyone
Yeah, buddy.
No, I hate you moves.
What?
Yeah, buddy.
Who are you trying to shoot?
No, they're not.
They're lucid, bro.
They got that.
Yeah, that's hard.
That's not the very I'm not gonna I ain't even gonna try that's a very difficult situation.
Oh, come here, man I'm hiding too.
I swear it's like who's here Yeah Jen Burton was actually hoed by his team.
That's crazy.
Oh, wait.
That was a different Val.
Dude, these altars are nuts.
Bro.
That's unfortunate.
Okay, just on the real, on the real, real, like just real quick.
No, no, no, no.
Moose, how many you on, bro?
Don't lie.
How many you on?
I'm on 17.
Oh, yeah.
Damn, guys.
I'm on 17, dude.
How many of you even see me?
Wait, Doki's on like 30.
Are you guys gonna kill that path?
Bro, I was trying to guess like this pathfinder!
Why you guys gotta freak him out!
I'm sad.
Who's getting it?
There's so many Valkyries.
Hey, not cool, buddy.
That was not cool.
what oh that is not cool guy i'm gonna run out of bullets it's not good there we go not cool at all i found an infinite ammo oh no shot that's cheap it's not a race for me guy no freaking loose i ain't racing here oh here we go there's so they're always back here man i'm telling you they're always here to the
hey I can't gaslight any of them anymore they know I'm a real player no that revenant was in such a good spot I should have gotten to our nines such a good spot and the rev got hoed so hard whoa he just jump scared me bro oh my god saying come back here I should have stole that from you
oh my god no no oh hey oh no oh oh oh i found oh i found it oh i found it's not a race what is happening there's so many there what is happening i'm gonna run out of ammo me too this is criminal wait how did they you're so scared no Brother, this is ridiculous.
Oh, you have ammo for me, shall we?
God damn.
He could kill him if you won.
That vanglers would.
No!
Duked again by the Valks!
Wait, there's a guy right here.
Valks keep duking me.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm clutch.
Oh my god.
This is ridiculous.
This is so silly!
Oh my god, bro.
Wait, so what happens if we die?
Um, if you don't get your skills, the chance to get all the kills.
Yeah, you don't get your skills.
The fact that I have assists make me sick.
Bro.
Oh, now I actually have to kill them.
Okay, no.
That's not good.
That's kind of nuts.
I'm thirsty.
Okay, everyone, this is...
They're all Valkyries!
No, I hate you.
What is going on?
Look at this altar, bro.
What am I looking at?
Okay, maybe I should have contributed more to this play.
Now there's too many people.
Oh my god, bro.
I'm just feeding them.
Oh my god.
Bro, a lot of people have a lot of HP, guys.
This is not good.
Oh my god, dude, that crypto has such a good play.
The fact that you have an infinite ammo is so cheese right now.
the fact that you have ammo is so cheese that's the biggest either scene oh i'm i don't we're dead we're dead i don't mean who's still alive who's still alive oh we won guys whoa we won yo geez that's so crazy we did it for charity we did it look how many do you have bro 30 probably i don't know man i wasn't playing the kill i was just having fun i was playing the mental warfare.
The fact that you found an infinite ammo is the most elite strat, though, because I didn't, I was literally chasing a horizon who was behind a rock, and I looked at the care package, and it had infinite ammo when I was down to 70 bullets.
And I was like, wait, that's the thing now?
There's infinite ammo.
Oh my god, I should have been looking at care packages.
That's an elite strat right there.
If there's ever been one, that's it.
I didn't realize that was a thing.
Wait, how many kills did I even have?
I have no idea.
It doesn't even let me see yeah me either i think like we i mean we had six guys we had 60 kills in total i don't know if that would help there is a possibility that we killed every single person in this lobby we should post a clip for that most kills in apex legends we should be an lgs 100 guys i knew i'm not winning this kill race because two of these players consistently play apex every single day to warfare like what I'm doing is to terrorize the hiding I can't believe that that was Greek
I am trying I've been informed it's also a lot of fun to terrorize like making them break their trust I just I want for a good solid so I don't know if the sound has been okay because No one has said anything.
I didn't know I was allowed to shoot them.
So I hope like my teammates haven't been too loud.
Have my teammates been too loud or anything?
I could lower them right now.
That was so sad, dude.
I don't know.
But following up that, I ran out of ammo like three times.
So I just had to look at people and like do everything I could to find ammo and it crafted.
Oh, they were loud.
Guys, why didn't y'all say anything?
Oh, I'm sorry.
They were drowning me out.
I'm sorry.
No, that's elite.
I've lowered them.
No, none of my sound people are awake right now.
pick up guns yeah shim had a freaking Kramer on his body bro wait I mean I am not joking but my normal mods if my sound team's not here you guys have to take over man he's nasty yeah but I gotta be like bro I gotta go yeah but then like you guys missed out on the gaslight can you guys still hear me gaslight
mod check wait all right none of my mods right here today this was okay i adjusted them is it better now is it better now oh yeah to still hear me thank god okay
oh just guy okay uh right so then when they started okay i lowered them a bit is it better
oh that sucks i didn't realize they were so I should have asked before we got in I watched the Doki Betrayal, it was a movie for real I Betrayed a, I'm here For the mental, I'm not, I'm Here for the mental warfare
Wait, I gotta play a different character I, wait, oh my God, wait, what were they playing, guys?
You're playing Octane Um Okay, okay um okay there was oct they were playing octane valc and pal i can't play okay i'll play octane i'm gonna play octane so they'll think that i'm one of them yeah if i play pathfinder they'll know that uh they'll know that uh i can't play valc though if i play pathfinder they'll know that um um they'll know that i'm the same I'm gonna play Octane just to just to fuck with them
No, but then they know the Pathfinder is the gaslighter.
They know they know the Pathfinder is the mental warfare gaslighter So I play Octane it'll be they won't
Because now they know now they know no true
the mind games yeah they won't know bro the fact that they're like and i like they're like oh i won't shoot i won't shoot now it didn't work i did but they're like oh i'm not gonna shoot i'm not gonna shoot take advantage of people that don't read the rules because i knew they didn't read because they thought it was a team game as well i thought it was a team game personally i'm having fun as a seeker no i'm saying this is sick i was just talking fun as a seeker it's like shooting little i was just talking trash to greek because i spammed finished him wait you did that too well i spammed finished greek as well well we both
you know what i'm saying hey don't be on the other end of it you know it is we both spam finish
that's crazy we both decide okay so how are they um how are they are they loud enough are they like quiet more um less quiet now they're not louder than me right i just want to make sure they're not louder than me that's all it's better do i try to lower them or keep them up better were they louder than me sorry like i i like i said like i had not a lot of not a lot of time to prep for this stream were they louder than me like before a bit a little okay okay okay that's okay i hate that i get really get like really uh peeved when like uh when like because you know it's my stream uh it's my stream i should be the loudest like you know like that that's how i perceive it it's like only i could be the loudest in my own stream but so so i gotta know i gotta know for hiding what's gonna be a little wild for the hiding part as things should be exactly exactly guys I'm having fun I'm having fun just messing with people like I said I am trying but like I know is to be right buddy um listen I
know that pivot and that's okay i think you might like i would not reach the same level as drum and moose i just have to run um so like i'm making it fun for me you know like oh yeah you never run out mo that's actually that's actually big brain i'm not gonna lie yeah i'm making the problem is like i don't know man so many fucking balks yeah it's really just people like running out like flying around you that's the problem like anyone who's like i thought i thought altar was going to be crazy like when i was first chasing the altar that i thought i couldn't shoot shout out doki um i was like no problem tracing altars all day but it's actually not that bad but the valks are in the valk and horizon with the glider is kind of nuts yeah i was kind of just gliding on people like officially get away from it is is altar recon or not recon no altar's not recon okay not recon okay okay thanks i'm gonna play altar so they'll think i'm part of them
Guys, I'll play Alter.
They'll think I'm part of their team.
Alter is even less suspicious than Octane.
Big break.
It's even less suspicious.
Oh my god, that is so...
true the thing is my teammates playing so well so like uh am i just like you guys just hate me forever if i just scoop your legend if i'm first pick or what what oh don't worry don't worry i don't think you'll scoop my legend i i absolutely think you'll scoop it what's what happens here what's you're trying to you try to take horizon from me bro i mean when you said the words gliding on people i'm like yo that's kind of big brain like maybe you know you need some sort vertical movement you do need move you definitely need like a rate that's definitely not to play i'm gonna have to figure something else out here let's see who gets first oh i don't think you're gonna pick my character so don't worry oh my god why am i lost again i'm sick no i won't say if you literally say bro don't take it i will not say no you you take it say less say less gang say less just know i like you like a little bit less no way no way no way you can't give you permission and it hurt me after i'm gonna be like
this no don't do me like this i'm just trying to win i'm just trying to get back to the kids man i'm trying to get back yeah yeah for the kids guys for the kids for the kids everyone it's for the children it's for the children exactly do you not like charity and maybe the abandoned dogs if i went i bet you're like why did she pick up this is the laundry chance well i might have dropped 60.
okay wait they're just gonna tell us where it's up again huh i thought we're just oh yeah the way at the end that's my assumption yeah it's my assumption but you know what they say about assuming launch pad all right there we go dang this is gonna be kind of nuts on stormpoint though okay i lowered them i lowered them but also i want to make sure you guys can hear what they're saying not be too quiet yeah but they don't there's a lot of altars though remember no guns for hatters okay but they're not gonna look at the my back one in the ship that's crazy here we go You can't even get tried in?
Fine.
Are they good now?
There's one little goober gobbler still in the ship.
I think they're just waiting for us to drop out.
But, like, they know where we're going to drop, though.
So, what's the point?
Yeah, but they're probably just going to, like, go to, like, Echo Station or something.
Not going to lie, though, the endgame was so fun.
Okay, now I know that Nemesis ain't it.
That was not the right gun.
Why is it stealing my loot, guys?
Not cool.
Hey, I heard that you're not allowed to shoot at people until...
No, it's now second zone.
Yeah, yeah, now you have to wait second zone.
You can't fight until ring three.
Yeah, ring three.
When we're hurting the cattle?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why don't we just wait until ring three and just hurdle them all in?
And just honestly, that's lucky.
Yeah, we should do that for the third match.
we just hurdle them into this final zone and just start spraying whoever listens whoever gets the numbers on their favor it's up yeah what it is whoa where the where the heck is any of the he killed someone already bro good for you man hey man you guys should have just been by me i don't know why you guys are running i'm vibing meds in the big two five i'm vibing right now i'm chilling oh dude i'm an idiot bro you know I've been stacking up on meds as well
Were we allowed to use nades I forgot Yeah, we can use anything we can use anything Oh wait a minute I know what to do No, I'm scared.
That's not fearing my heart.
No, this is just...
No, they should be the one fearing.
I'm picking up some Nades.
You guys might think it's foolish, but...
I can't hear you.
Watch till the end game.
Oh, no, my...
Watch at end game on what I'm going to do to these people.
I'm just going to blow them up.
Honestly, maybe Fuse is the pick for end game.
Look, he...
Just rip a Fuse ulti?
Throw mad Nades everywhere?
We're cooking.
Oh, wait, I'm...
Oh, I know what.
I'm picking.
next my obs crashed oh oh that's not good guys we're really spread out should we get closer hey i'm not gonna stay but like when you look at the teammates you have a speed boost it'll help me run down people so easy okay yeah now this is gonna be so much harder to find people
oh no dude my internet's just getting cooked yeah this is not the time for it to be getting cooked yeah it's a little that's a little oopsie why is that door open why is this door open because i opened it you know i'm sorry i was there but at the same time i'm i'm i'm this is my opportunity you know what i mean no it was me i was i was the one that was over there just recently i want to believe you but you know i don't think that's ever again possible ever again are you even are you even dokey is that even my real name am i just the voice is in your head you actually don't even have a third teammate i'm just delusional at this point i've lost all sense of reality it's over
don't worry guys i'm gonna start hiding infinite ammo will in fact be on this care pack i'm Infinite ammo.
Okay, so what other things do they give you now other than infinite ammo?
Because that's wild.
There's the fast cooldown, like faster cooldown ability one.
There's the over- That's wild.
Like, you pop a cell and you slowly heal all the way up to full.
There's one that does that.
That should be like a team perk.
Not- Yeah, one person gets it.
Everybody gets it.
Yeah, yeah, I feel like everyone should get it.
I'm just gonna start hiding.
If I start hiding, maybe other people will hide with me.
Surely there's going to be some hiders coming here, right?
Friends shouldn't be so distant.
Surely.
Dude, where are these people?
They're so good.
I know, right?
John, you're cheating.
Confirmed.
There's no one on this side of the map that I can terrorize?
I don't know, man.
I'm kind of just...
Dude, there's no one on this side.
I'm surprised Yeah, why are they all on that side?
I guess it's like closer.
Oh, I guess it's because closer to us.
That would make sense I was trying to see if there's any hide is that are drifting in I'm allowed to use redeploys, right?
Yeah, we can use we can use anything they can't use everything but we can use anything.
Our only rule is a Not teaming, I guess, right?
I don't know why that's against the rules, but yeah.
We're going to wait and see if anybody is in here, but.
Where are the...
I just...
I want you guys to know I just maniacally gaslit two people that make me think that I was hiding with them, and I just remember...
Oh, that's been my strat this entire time.
In cold blood.
My strat involves no deceiving.
No manipulation.
Just pure skill?
That's so boring.
You're so vanilla, bro.
Hey, somebody just hit this.
Somebody just hit this thing.
I don't know why I pinged that out.
I didn't think we were gonna lie.
Bro, good cops.
Good cops.
On the way.
I'm pulling up.
He doesn't know.
Wait, there's like nobody on this side.
It's actually crazy.
It's hard.
I haven't seen a single person at all.
This map makes it so much harder.
The fact that I'm not killing her though, it hurts.
It hurts inside.
Maybe?
Oh, I think they might be on this side.
broke that enemy shield now dude they're all gone oh there's noctane over here
oh wait what did i hear that from wait that is troll we have time i hear it I heard a jump cannon just now.
Hello there, we can hide together.
Don't you want to hide with me?
I'm coming for you.
Moo, stop!
Dude, I'm just trying to find one.
I only have one kill, bro!
Wait, Doki has like 30.
Yeah.
No.
Oh my god.
Operation, chat, Operation Grief Doki.
Start now.
Three seconds remain.
The ring is nearby.
and group doggie yeah
bro I'm sick oh there's the octane over here I've only seen those two people I bamboozled out and then outside of that that's it pick me up I just I should have played revved it it was hard chasing revs too they keep eating everywhere honestly forget that he has like the leap which is really silly but oh it's a way better than the path you grab oh oh oh Time to grief me!
Time to grief me!
Hey buddy.
What if I go to your hiding spot, little guy?
Dude, where are these people?
This guy doesn't know if I'm friendly or not.
Incoming care package.
Are they?
He's a doater.
Why would they not know?
Unless he's a...
the guns on my back and then hey there I still see you octane hey guy you still chilling you're still alive I'm playing this incredible long game with this one octane don't kill him I'm marinating him oh I see somebody yes yes finally did he go Bro, I'm about to finally jump.
I'm about to run a sniper.
Oh, did my little marinated octango?
That's a Valk.
There's someone hiding invisibly.
Oh, yes.
Oh, there's a lot of people.
I killed a Valk.
I'm not gonna lie, that's about his crew.
Wait, there's so many up there.
Doki, what is that?
Collecting them.
Why are you pumping them all?
I'm hurting the cattle right now
I'm hurting the cattle.
What are you talking about?
I saw you back here.
You're invisible.
You're invisible aren't you?
No!
I'm sick!
Oh, fuck it.
He's gone.
I can't get him.
No, guys, don't worry.
I will do something silly soon.
Guys, don't worry.
Guys, don't expose my location because I'm gonna do something really silly.
I think all you've done is something silly this whole time.
But I need them to trust me.
And if you guys run up to them, they're gonna disperse like a little rabbit.
they are the little rats they are is crazy so I need you guys to not be near me when I do my long con oh my god bro I should just fumble so bad oh my god what is that way he's invisible like right here they're like right here somewhere I know you are is there a flicker on the on crypto still where are the little corner hideers no no no no no no no come over here go away go away go away go away Go away.
Go away.
What do you mean?
No, no, no, no, no, no, go away.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
No, no.
Yes.
Drum, you garbage dirt ball.
Yeah, it doesn't feel good, does it?
It doesn't feel good.
Here we go.
The next ring.
The fun will come to us.
Oh my god, dude, that that ball is insane.
Where'd they go?
Did they take the valkal?
Oh my god, it was so bad.
I didn't even see it.
There's a...
Yeah, there's...
Bro, they all like...
They're all like hiding really good.
It's like it's hide and seek or something.
They're all...
They're really good at hiding.
They're not hoeing me right now.
Yeah!
It's for the children!
Anybody can get hold for the children, brother.
Wait, someone took a car here.
What?
Why is there a car?
They're actually hiding really, really good.
wait what the what is that spot what is that spot that's an insane spot that was elite that's elite gameplay from this wait is that part of in zone but that is that is in zone yeah oh deeds deeds that was smooth i like that deeds i'm not gonna lie to you that was you gotta go i am so bad with this triple tank somebody get it out of my hands it's so embarrassing how bad i need you to keep being bad i need you to keep being bad my turn he gives up man it's time that's another kill i could bleed out can you take those i know you're hiding over here somewhere come on crouch come on rave just stand still you little bruh oh he's not gonna stand still oh my goodness bro oh my goodness dude these bouts are so they're so paranoid now bro these you guys are so paranoid
No, that's not gonna save you that's not gonna save you that's not you might think it is but you're mistaken That's not gonna save you
We're up
Where'd you go little buddy there you are I think I'm gonna get rezzed.
I might have one kill, but that kill was the best kill I've ever got.
You guys forgot I can use abilities?
Oh, look at him!
Look at him running!
No, no, no, no.
Don't you dare.
Bro, what is this?
No, no, no.
Oh, guess what?
I know who the real one is, and he just got left.
And he just got left.
Ha!
I'm sorry, I had to happen to me.
But it's for charity.
Yay, charity.
It's for charity, gaming merchant.
Oh, man, I'm so annoyed.
Yeah, it happened, big dog.
This one, I'm getting cooked.
Yay, charity.
I'm not gonna lie, there's somebody competing.
Bro, I'm getting cooked right now.
I have, like, almost 3k damage with four kills.
They're just alluding you, bro.
They're allusive.
Noose, I might have to come still at from you.
No.
Oh, my God, dude.
There's actually no way that he survives.
No, I got him.
Don't worry.
One of them was hiding here.
Oh.
Oh, they're just jumping.
Oh, she doesn't trust me.
I wonder why.
Wait, I ran so quick.
Wait.
Where'd he go?
Wait, wait.
He was just right here.
No, I just...
My goodness.
Wait.
Wait, no, you're here.
I don't care.
You don't trust me.
I gotta take that off.
I just ran into a crypto invisible, but he...
Ah, there you are.
Ah, boom!
Wait, that was elite, which has happened on my screen.
That was crazy.
Oh, I'm sorry.
They're coming behind me still.
That was an elite height.
I'm not gonna lie.
Let's try to get it.
Again.
Wait, how are you back?
Oh my god.
How did you get rest?
Bruh.
My gun choice this game was just not good.
I'm happy about my gun choice.
Why are they so scared?
They're just going back and forth.
I think Altair was the perfect character to play mind games because they think I'm part of the team.
Oh, I'm just farming gaming right here.
They got to stop Resident Evil.
They got to stop it.
What did you think was going to happen here?
Oh no.
Altair is such a good character.
Yeah, go ahead.
Let's go ahead and get that.
man why why are you why are you doing that for the kids the problem is the real problem i'm running into there's a real problem i'm running into yeah what is it there's a real problem i'm running into here there's a lot of people oh do you guys not have enough ammo now i don't know my okay so the real problem right now that um we might have left a lot of people alive I'm getting throttled again my internet oh no not the internet oh this is terrible my internet is just getting cooked somebody please that picks up ammo please good Samaritan oh no no no and there's no this is gonna be bad this is gonna be so bad
Mr. C7 in, please, no, no, no, no, no, no, I have no ammo, please, give me!
I'm like, oh, he got a freaking armor swap.
Oh, what?
Oh, man.
I know I didn't kill you, but...
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Why do they never expect it's me?
Oh.
They keep forgetting.
Oh, my God, bro.
Caution, my boy.
These people keep forgetting.
I love you, Gajun.
All right, buddy.
That's crazy.
Look at this fast.
I have to do a better.
This is my only option here.
It's my only option here.
I'm out of ammo.
Please.
There we go.
Bro, that movement ain't helping you, buddy.
Oh my God, bro.
I don't know what I'm supposed to do here.
I don't even know what I can do here.
Yeah, I'm waiting till end game for my brilliant strat Stop it.
Oh my goodness.
I might.
Oh, no, no, no.
You were so close to dying Dude, this is nuts.
Okay.
It's all just bounce and ziplines How do you saw how bullets move?
How?
You don't know how to fire jetpack.
I'm finishing it.
Is this zone closing now?
No!
Freak you, Moo!
So I worked so hard for that one kill.
Yeah!
All right, Clara.
You gotta go.
All right.
Oh, oh, this is not good.
I'm just stuck floating.
It doesn't even be floating.
No, I'm not killing her anymore.
No, Moo!
I hate you, bro.
You're the only one with bullets.
I was just there.
What's that?
Okay.
Oh my god.
What a big brain.
Who's OP?
Please.
Oh no.
Worth it.
I just ran.
Oh no.
Worth it.
I won.
Bro.
I just, you had ammo.
Let me tell you something.
You had so much ammo.
Bro, how did you still have ammo?
There's no way, bro.
I just ran.
out of ammo i was cooking i was at 20 and i just had no ammo bro i had i literally i ran out of white ammo bro i was just ripping with my t-take that's all i did that's smart wait until the end game with the triple take when drum had no more ammo i didn't i didn't try to do that i want to let it be known like that wasn't my plan or scheme okay having struggles in the first half of the game is elite because like you you're only gonna get a couple kills like all the are going to come end game yeah exactly it's the end game you got to wait until the end game big 66 that time big 66 66 what is uh wait so how many do you have moose at 20.
okay so next time i'm bringing how many grenades let me know how many kills that i have i'm gonna get grenades grenades i only have i literally had four guys do i get arc star for end game uh the dude why doki betrayed me and acted like a hide you gotta be specific because because it was a lot of people i betrayed you were like running around punching people dog he was throwing like fire grenades at people i was sitting on a rock and just hit fire my triple tank that's all i was doing yeah it's all i was doing that's all i did man that's literally all i did i did nothing okay guys guys yeah all i as alter they all thought i was part of the team and i had chilled with me none of them suspected me at all all right all right guys uh guys what what uh alter okay what these are so fun which one okay yeah it's too obvious which what are characters were they playing other than alter it was alter pathfinder uh Ulter pathfinder What else valk rave oh crypto oh my god I got odd no cryptos recon
That sucks.
Yeah, I wish I could play crypto Octane that's so unfortunate.
Okay, do we do octane that is so unfortunate Okay, I'm gonna play octane now
I can't, dude.
Alright, I'll do Octane.
Guys, if I play Cossack, guys, the thing is, if I play Cossack, they all know it's me.
Oh my god, wait, Cossack, last zone, Connolly, wait, no.
Oh my, wait, I don't care.
I don't care.
I'm just, I don't care about the long, I'm going to do the long game.
Wait, no.
Wait, that, this is Connolly.
We're the, I'm the content person here.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, imagine.
Costing up 20, my entire loadout would be Costing up and 20 names.
I'll just, my entire, I won't even shoot people.
It'll just be like, um,
I was hitting the foot that got stuck with.
Don't keep betraying everyone.
I told him it's time to be a superstar.
Let's go again.
Here we go again, buddy.
Will Moose be first or last?
Maybe picking.
Okay.
As God, I'm going to be last again, dude.
Like I don't know why it should surprise anybody.
I'm not going to lie.
I'm not going to go for her.
I love Apex Legends.
Bro, I'm going to get Karma so hard.
I'm just scheming.
I love Apex Legends.
you're gonna let drum up win the third game
hey man shoot or shoot dude from anywhere i respect it no the seekers can they said we can game respects game game without respect game game respect listen at the end of the day everybody wins at the end of the day everybody wins where's caustic guys oh here Leave the chat,
leave the chat.
No, you read what Evan said.
You literally read what Verhoel said.
I mean, that's just, that's just, that's such a, that's such a big brain play, though.
Oh, you're not expecting what I'm playing.
Bro, what?
What is this?
Oh my God.
Oh no.
No.
I'm an idiot.
I should have played Beard.
I was thinking about Emma.
Oh my God.
Dude, that end game, you're just going to get power with the shield.
Yes.
I don't even care about the beginning of the game.
It's about the end.
No way.
They're gonna see a caustic and they are pissed.
They're gonna see the caustic and be like, alright.
I'm waiting till the last zone.
I ain't participating until then.
That's all you need to do.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
I'm assuming they're gonna- Santa's coming.
I know who's been nodding.
Boundary, Atmos.
It's about sending a message.
Yeah.
Christmas, this game really.
Let's go, baby.
Guys, how many barrels can I have up again?
Guys, how many?
I was not smart.
I read what he said to you.
I stole his whole flow.
I thought he was going to pick her, but you got first picks.
I was like, I'll get it.
I'll go to...
Who even is winning in this kill?
Like, who's winning in the lead right now between you two?
Oh, moves by far.
self-image it's 100 and you're going for a spitfire right away you freak you freak of nature you freak i'm a creature right now i'm feeling like a creature a pure freak it's over it's actually i'm feeling like a creature i love it oh my this guy's despicable okay stop picking up med drum that's really dumb very dumb of you don't be don't be doing a lot i'll be doing a lot I'm just going to camp one of these things and just grab ammo as much as I possibly can.
I have everything I need.
I don't even need...
I don't think I even need a second gun, technically.
I don't know if you even need to shoot a bullet.
I don't even think I need a shoot a bullet.
You don't even need to shoot a singular bullet.
This is so fun.
I need a better bag.
Let it be known that I do, in fact, have two Spitfires, not just one.
Oh, my.
I went with...
damn that's crazy bro unreal it is nice stacking way more ammo though i am a creature today i can't wait to hide though i'm kind of excited to hide i didn't yeah me too i feel kind of like jealous of the people who get to hide right now i do not feel jealous and so hectic i do not feel just jealous of them while i'm doing to them yeah well this game for sure that's pretty rude I like tricked up Bangalore,
we chilled, and then I took out two arc stars and stuck her.
I think .
Yeah, you're a demon type.
You're a demon type.
You're moving different.
You're a dickhead, dude.
That's what I'm saying.
I don't want to be hiding what I'm doing to these people.
I'll do whatever for charity at this point.
I'll do whatever.
Yeah.
If that means you almost go back.
Like I know I'm not winning the kill race, but I'm winning the mental warfare.
Just playing psychological warfare.
Yeah.
That's the real W.
That's the real win.
That's the true win.
I'm out.
Later, nerds.
Anybody want that?
This is the completely wrong direction.
Oh my god, guys.
If I put two ultimate excels, I throw it once and then I can, I'll alt excel, waiting.
I'll alt excel in a horizon alt and throw another alt down.
I do it for the night.
love of the game guys wait i'm handling business um wait okay how many barrels can i have at once to see somebody sitting true how many all excel does it take for me to guys how many all excel does it take for me to uh to get an all for caustic is it two or three do i need two or three guys oh wait yeah i just got i just go i'm just gonna go like double oh my god
okay boom i should exploit its upgrade plus two traps in the world my dog extra traps i literally heard him now wait does that mean um i have five now i heard him go in the thing and then i saw can i have five now like that little uh you know how he's in his drone how like yeah you can see blink he was just like close enough to me yeah i literally ran directly into a throw that was in the in the drum last game i did not know was there oh dude you should have seen what i did to uh you should see what i did to giggle by accident in the first game i was chasing a valkyrie and like she had like hit her thrusters i don't care that they're running away because i'm i need and then i was starting to shoot her and track her but then i ended up hitting uh giggle in No,
she's caught a stray.
Yeah, she's just caught a stray.
Sorry.
I say my teammates can get me to purple But I am in fact finding I'm waiting for my teammates to get me purple.
I also need a better backpack too I don't yet people is crazy this early.
Hey guys, can you ping me a purple backpack?
This is very important Yeah, I need a purple backpack guys I got you there you go Got extra supplies here.
A prepared soldier is a living soldier.
I guess the purple back.
Yeah, chat, we're swapping after this game.
So we have three games as seekers and three games as hiders.
Yeah, I'm stoked to be able to hide.
It's going to be sick.
I feel like I'm going to get carbon so hard as hider.
I wonder how they do points.
That's a great way.
It's like the longer you last, I think, like whichever placement your hider team gets.
Because the hider is the team game.
See, like now again, like that sounds normal, but I still don't trust you from right now.
No, that's the actual rule.
Don't worry, I'm gaslighting the hiders, not you guys now.
I have new targets.
Oh, you could focus on someone else.
All right, that's good to know.
Are you even finding people?
Also, can you guys ping me?
I'm finding them, I'm finding them like over, over in the quarantine zone, but they're all kind of meandering away from me, which I guess is the name of the game.
But yeah, I think it's because you have a gun on your back.
Maybe Maybe you like throw away your gun because I'm shooting bullets at people that might yeah, yeah, that's very possible Yeah, yeah, I think you got to stop doing that
Oh, oh, oh, oh, but where the heck are the alt excels chat what's on my fellow?
I've been trying to fight I don't care about these people.
Oh, wait.
Hey, I need that actually.
I don't care about like the people around me This is I need an alt Excel you're so fearful You have nothing but fear in your heart.
Just know that.
I'm not here to kill people now.
Oh, wait, unless.
Eh.
I can't marinate this person because he knows.
This sucks.
Drum, you are always killing Thumbos.
Okay, help me.
Do you have a purple backpack?
I'll kill you if you have a purple backpack, bro.
Thumbos got to go down.
For the kids.
Look at this.
I'm here for the purple backpack.
I don't care.
Not on my dog Thumbos, but he's got to die.
Got to go, got to go.
Somebody had to do it.
Somebody.
I had to beat Thumbos.
I need to look for loot.
Like, my plan needs the proper loot for this, and I don't have the proper loot yet.
I'm not here for the kills now.
I'm here for the long-term kills.
game kills i need i literally guys if you guys find alt excels ping me i need like two more for my master plan yeah for sure i got you for sure hell yeah i'm not gonna lie the kill feed is it's gonna be oh no just cross the gas oh oh my god my god should i place traps i should you're so right
I just placed random traps here and there.
How many of you have right now?
Three?
I think I've counted three.
Maybe four.
I'm only at three, brother.
I'm only at three.
I'm assuming 15.
And I'm being gaslit.
I have no trust in this team right now.
Zero.
You should just have no trust in me.
I don't know why you're bringing Moose into this.
I'm glad that you admit it.
Yeah, it's like, why are you bringing Moose into this?
Ikey, Ikey, Ikey.
You're not a moose.
I can't believe I still haven't found a backpack, guys.
It's crazy.
I've just been, like, trying to find old excels and backpacks.
That was been the entire plan.
Oh, dude, where is this?
Alright.
Dude, that drone moves pretty fast.
Can't lie.
like I know my team isn't being a team right now I can't believe it my teammate helping yell I don't understand why not
hey oh my god dude I just made eye contact with somebody and started loading up bro bro I'm the only Cossack you're so okay do you have a backpack oh my god let's go that's actually what I needed I had to kill him for for that while I take out this crypto those are the real problems there we go okay more nades I can finally have more nades oh wait I oh my god where am I going where am I going there a Christmas came early guys oh no oh no he has cracked the enemy shield oh nice a reset I needed that I needed this yeah infinite ammo ah no infinite ammo all right
I need Alt-Excel still.
Jesus, where are the Alt-Exceles?
It's like, we're so poor here.
I don't hate it.
I mean, I'll take that.
I feel so poor.
Yo, this Crypto just honed.
He's so bad.
Bro, I feel like the hodders are taking all the Alt-Excel because they know my plan.
They're like, we can't give them.
give the costing from the end game gas which is understandable wait infinite ammo where no right come back I don't know what it looks like chat oh is it this oh okay I guess I can start shooting
Wait a minute, but more room for names.
Guys, you know I don't read.
You know that.
I'm sad.
I've been, like, trying to find all the cells this whole time.
It's time.
There's a trap.
Merry Christmas, buddy.
Bro, guys, come on.
I need more.
guys I need more alt excels guys come on guys come on what do I just gas this area damn you guys are so focused right now zero die like I'm not gonna lie I was just giggling at you throwing her oh yeah yeah yeah Christmas came early I'm giving them the presents I am,
in fact, being a bit of a dirtball.
Not a huge dirtball.
But enough of one.
Oh, bro, this ends up sucks for me, bro.
Yeah, it's too open.
It's so open.
How am I supposed to...
Oh, they could just go top or bottom.
That's the worst part.
How do I gas up one area if there's multiple areas?
have an altar they're ripping altar plays what bro that's just embarrassed jen that is so embarrassing you know what i'm gonna do jen you know
drum why are you why are you lurking don't worry about me dude no about me, bro.
Hey, what about yourself?
Oh no.
That was very cool.
You know what, let's just not talk to you.
You know what?
I'm getting a lot of brock.
I'm a lot of brock.
Fuck you.
No one's picking your body up.
Oh, that's weird.
I'm getting bamboozled.
Yeah, no one picking your body up, buddy.
Oh, you gotta go.
You gotta go, Jack.
Caution!
Oh, wait, no, this is the perfect end zone.
This is the perfect end zone for me.
No, I'm getting distracted!
I'm getting distracted!
There's too many of them!
It's time.
many of them oh my god these guys are nuts their movement is so good they're so good
oh five right and the naughty list is very long
this is a long naughty list
I gotta catch up to Moose.
I think Mandy just hones somebody so hard.
And waiting.
What is he doing?
Oh, I need to save my gas.
Oh, I can have eight?
That's a crazy spot, dude.
There's a Valkyrie doing something crazy.
Dude, they're all doing crazy stuff, bro.
That Valkyrie is doing something crazy.
I'm getting up with some devious work over here.
I can't lie to you.
Dude, I have 10, so I don't know.
You're 5.
I'm only at 11, bro.
Guys, how many do I have left on the screen?
Those guys are cracked.
How many do I have left on the screen, guys?
I don't know.
Oh, dude!
No!
You almost got that from me.
I'm being such a villain.
I am horrified.
Oh, wait.
What do you think this one, buddy?
Santa Claus is coming to town.
No.
Santa Claus is coming.
The Claus is coming to down.
He knows when you are heeping.
He knows when you are awake.
He knows when you're awake.
His name's Yikes!
Josh!
No, my boy.
I thought you were going to slay anyone like somebody.
I know.
It's right here.
Guess who has 20 names?
Oh my god, I got bamboozles so bad.
They're all in the right, oh my god, they're all in the queue.
Santa Claus is coming to town.
I'm saving it.
Oh, they're trying to up my traps away.
What is going on?
That's not cool.
Oh my goodness, bro.
They're all up on height.
I literally don't even have audio.
My audio went out.
The game broke.
My audio.
My audio doesn't work.
Oh, here you gotta go, bro.
I'm ready.
Oh my god.
What is happening?
I don't know, man.
I have no ammo.
What is going on right now?
I took damage.
They're all up in the air.
This is so dumb.
I don't even know what's happening.
I don't know where you're at.
Gotta see you, reload.
The worst part is boom.
Hold his own.
This is crazy.
I died, bro.
You died?
Yo, Donky is just raking in the kill.
Donky's not getting- No, wait!
Donky's killing me now!
Oh, oh my god!
Oh my god!
Oh, how many kills are you?
you get there i have 22 i'm like donkeys just randomly just i lost pillator at the last second what even just happened yeah the rampart was not going my way just because i got 32 kills in the end it was so long i told you it was the long time i also had seven nades that i chucked in at the end i wasn't shooting until then i got infinite ammo by the way so i didn't need to bring a stack of ammo i didn't run an ammo this time thankfully no you cooked you took out of your mind that's so funny that was crazy oh i told you guys Bro.
That's so good.
That's what that is.
Dude, all I saw was the feet.
No, the nades don't hurt.
Their nades don't do anything to the costing of it.
Death the ring.
Don't.
Yeah.
Cause like I threw 20 nades and they all pushed, it pushed everyone out into the ring.
You cooked.
Yeah.
Absolutely cooked right there.
That was nothing.
From two to 32 kills.
That's great.
Two kills.
Like the last ring closing.
Yeah.
that's pretty nuts I
told you guys I could all I should have been costing the entire time yeah I was too I was too into the carnage I think I only had like 18 so the rest was you guys honestly that's the wait does the alt actually die to thermite i thought it was i didn't wait did they change that usually usually nades don't do anything the cost they got when was that bro this is i don't keep up when was that changed
i did not know that when i saw 20 nades if i knew that rb rbs
did they actually wait really may dissipate the gas yeah oh it's still going for a while
all right who's playing crypto i'll rip mirage merry christmas well i'll play anything i i'm Or I could just go...
Or I could probably go Valp too.
Bro.
We're going...
Not the...
Oh, it was just the Barrels.
Aw, man.
If I knew that, wouldn't I have thrown 20...
If I knew that, I wouldn't have thrown 20 names.
What if I...
What if I go Costic just to avoid...
What if they play Costic, so I go Costic to avoid the cast?
Do you think they'll go caustic?
I don't think that you'd be...
I don't think that you'd...
No, you get affected.
You get affected by the caustic gas.
Wait, you get affected now?
Yeah, and you can't play anybody with damage when you're hiding.
Yeah, but I can...
I'm just trying to be immune to the gas.
Wait, we get a...
Oh my god!
As long as I don't...
You can play anything as long as you don't use any of the damage.
damage abilities.
But I could have taken this entire tournament.
Honestly, as a seeker, I could have just taken the entire tournament by just going Kossik the last three rounds.
But honestly, the mental warfare was so fun, though.
Like, each round, I'm literally the content for this tournament.
It's not about the race.
It's about the mental warfare.
They're all gonna remember my Kossik.
They're all gonna remember my caustic.
They're real.
Yeah, it got zoomed up.
The fact that I, the fact that I went from like three kilos and then I think it's because I also nated people outside the ring, too.
It's always about sending a message.
All right, what do we play, guys?
What should we play?
Oh, 7 to 32.
Yeah.
The Doki Bird Bell Curve.
Oh,
we could do bamboozle.
That's true.
Are you guys running caustic seekers?
Bro, I see.
I told you the caustic PTSD.
guys we did this together this is a team game we did this together guys the meta has yeah i remember in like all the other hide and seek no one would play classic but we we cooked chat you you and i we both cooked the perfect the perfect strap ride and seek yeah no we're we're hiders now
joki got more ports that game than most teams will get the whole event I'm done like Bro
Alright first time hiding It's about to get real Okay okay yeah So what we play and what we play Um probably Valc for sure Okay I think I'll play Horizon Valc Horizon and then I don't know what the other one would be What like?
Wraith was kind of nutty like dealing with Wraith like back yeah right wasn't bad crypto was pretty good mirage is pretty good oh mirage might be a lead i'll say mirage mirage might be but i crafted the new hide and seek meta no one's played caustic before until i yeah they better whoever's the seekers they're gonna be running caustic now yeah 100 every hide and seek tournament is just gonna be caustic now oh 100 straight caustics every time a hundred percent
bro i bro we theory crafted
we theory crafted all right i think i could have won the entire charity event if i went caustic three times in a row uh but but that ain't what we are do we caused trauma to several people we got you know we had to swap it up you know first it was just hiding with the regular the regular people and then and then we we became one of them oh what are you gonna do when they show build a wall yeah i'm gonna build walls dude what are they gonna do i was on my phone looking at a trade-off or that somebody sent me.
There's already clips.
Yeah, chat, I'm hitting the panic button in my one league because I have now lost four in a row because every single week one player just puts up zero.
Like tell me how Odunze puts up zero when the Bears are putting up 47 on the bangles.
Tell me how.
All right, if you insist.
Jen sent me a clip of my jinn jinn jinn sent me a clip of of what i did to him surround and he sent me the middle finger right after so we can't do anything right we literally can just no it's just hide it's hot and see you wouldn't that's great i'm gonna just sit here and tell his own and we'll see what You guys are sleeping on this meta.
Bro, I can't look at it right now.
No, low key, they might think that you're the seeker.
You know, other people, they might think that you're the seeker.
Bro, I think we all saw the champion.
Oh, wait, you're right.
The champion screen wasn't the seekers.
No, it wasn't, yeah, it wasn't.
It's going to be locked.
I guess I threw it.
Yeah.
I'm actually cooked.
Dang, low key, spare.
Is a good pick, too.
People are hating, like, squirrel cues.
Ooh, that's true.
Where are the heels?
Like, on Seeker.
You know what I mean?
Like, you just know exactly where...
Oh, you can't remember because we can't even play freaking recon, so never mind.
No, no, they can't play recon.
We can.
Oh, I guess we should grab heels now, huh?
Yeah.
Also, we can...
I'm pretty sure we can play recon.
They can't, right?
We can't play recon.
Yeah, we can play, yeah.
I was gonna say.
It didn't make no sense.
Also, we should really have purple army no that's okay yeah let's stretch we should really grab guys we're a team now i need to remind you all that we're all a team now also where did they land they landed uh thermal on my ping guys if we find the end game i'm just gonna be like running around placing walls everywhere i mean you can oh wait i'm running towards them i should run no we're in the next beacon yeah yeah we should yeah let's just find the end game oh that's why we got you That's why you picked Rampart,
right?
You're trying to find the endgame.
Yeah, this is it.
This is it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come here, come here, come here, come here, come here.
Come here, come, come, come.
Go, go, I'm gonna hit this.
Oh, okay, okay, I'm gonna.
Okay, okay, so...
So...
I'm flying over to launch site.
Where do you guys think endgame's gonna be?
Practice your zone prediction.
Probably tree, right?
It's time to practice your zone prediction.
It's gotta be tree, yeah.
It's gonna be a tree, like, for sure, yeah.
It's probably gonna, like, am I right on that corner or something?
So you can come out of hiding.
Slowly going to thermal right now.
What do I get?
Okay.
Alright, I'm heading the tree and I'm chilling in tree.
If I get shot, I get shot.
I think it's karma for everything I've done today.
Guys, if I die, it's just karma.
Like, I deserve it.
If I die, I fucking deserve it.
It's karma for the crimes I've committed today.
I mean, yeah, bro, I don't even care if I die early, bro.
What I did was absolutely horrible.
Like, I don't think anyone ever played caustic before in Highland Seek until today.
Until today.
Like, as a seeker.
People play caustic in High, like, in Melee.
but no one's ever thought of a playing cost because like you know everyone was like oh we gotta run at people and get the moose kills but no one ever thinks about the end game no one we could we saw the the nade stuff and then we're like wait a minute this could get even better there's no way i'm creating new worm crimes i haven't came back to apex in so long The first thing I do is invent a war crime A war crime meta See this is why It's good that I took a break from Apex guys We got new ideas coming in
Oh my god We could have went Gibby Could have went Gibby too
Imagine Gibby ulting The last zone Oh my Oh my god I want to be a hider again.
I- Oh, I want to be a hider.
We only had so many rounds that we could cook.
We all- write that down.
I thought that- I didn't think that they patched the spot.
I didn't think they patched the spot.
I'll grab your- Oh, you can sit it back.
Remember what I did for you.
I grabbed your banner.
I know.
Someone else has to rest because it ain't me.
Dude, listen.
I thought you could lay there.
I thought you could sit there.
Oh, God.
Now there's a giant beacon telling the freaking cheaters.
Yep.
Look at what you did.
Not everyone's going to run here because of you.
And this is end zone.
Don't worry, guys.
We'll be fine.
Where can we?
You know what?
This is karma for the crimes I've committed.
This is actual karma.
This is this is karma right here.
It's already coming.
Wait, they looted my bin.
They looted my body.
Yeah, I looted your body.
No, I stole his meds.
No, I think this raid stole all.
Dude, they all stole my meds.
That's on you.
Shouldn't have climbed.
We're on a team!
Wait, where did you die from?
Like, back here where I'm at?
uh yeah dude you can't okay so you see that little like ledge underneath there you only so many secret rounds we can get i'm so sad i wish i could have played i wish we got all the secret rounds so i could have played gibby guys i am so sad imagine oh my god that would have been so good i got 32 kills i would have got like all 50 kills
dang i'm looking at the actual skill issue i can't i just save my life buddy i literally cannot find a good spot at all i'm just i think i think i'll be i think people will find me but that's okay guys does my outfit match does my outfit match with the zone i can't even wait you're outlining for me no matter what it's like useless if it's indoors that's true but i uh but like i believed in I believe in all of us Being outside Like I was like hoping that we were all We were all going to be outside for it My greed Have no limits Winner POV Yeah where are you Wait let me let me out there I probably I'm probably definitely going to be able to see it Well I got like 10 seconds my boy Yeah just Right here and I'm scared Yeah but I don't I don't hear gunshots I'm setting up some distractions Send up some distractions Bro we show Oh my god.
Wait, wait.
Lift me up.
I swear to god, you predicted the wrong zone, bro.
I predicted the wrong zone.
The possibility it moves.
No, you're right.
Yes, this is it.
This is the strat.
What is the strat?
The strat sitting there.
You're so obvious, bro.
You're so...
No, no, no.
There's no way.
Don't, don't, the thing is, they don't know that you pick Rampart, so no one will be, like, looking for a Rampart, you know?
Because that's, like, the most stupid thing you can do as a hider.
And you beat them.
you beat them with dumb actually no listen listen you put up well how many walls can you have about like five or something you should put just like random wall spots like along that's what i'm doing that's what that's what i did yeah yeah it's like more like in all and just pick one of the most obvious ones they'll never get apparently taxi picked up a gun and killed phony but he's not a seeker of course there he goes there he goes again why would you do that bro they have some kind apparently also why the fuck are you in my spot bro we're if a secret finds us we are both we are both literally four shields i should be okay all right here we go let's see your end zone prediction if it's good or not it's gonna pull forward now watch something like here yeah we have to go all the way to the other side what if it pulls here it goes all the way to the other side there's an There is a good spot right there.
All right, who did the zone prediction so we could blame them?
Me, blame me, blame me.
Oh.
Guys, this is a brilliant plan, I think.
In 48 seconds.
In 48 seconds, we're gonna figure it out.
Yeah, they're like, yeah, I saw that, too.
I saw taxi kill people.
Okay, so I don't hear gunshots, so I feel like they might be on the other side of the map.
My little personal mischie.
I'm just waiting to end game to start shooting.
Oh, Clary's got a kill.
Never mind.
No, they got like three kills so far.
Wait, is it like kill race overall six people or kill race overall three of us?
That's actually a good comment.
I have no idea.
Yeah, yeah.
So am I like against you guys?
All the fellas are here with me.
Are they all with you?
All the fellas are here with you.
They're like chilling with you up in your house.
You know, this is great.
Listen, they, look, they're gonna live there.
They're gonna have no idea we're down here.
We're chilling.
Shoot them.
They won't look down.
The look up.
Massive zone.
Good zone prediction.
He made a lit up.
He made like an actual refugee house for everyone.
Like everybody is welcome.
Everybody is welcome.
He made like a fucking bunker.
Like...
I gotta go, I gotta go bunker up.
Yeah, yeah, it's like fallout right now.
Yeah.
Listen.
Looky, listen.
We have to have a strat.
We have this list at the moment.
Yeah.
One second.
If we're in there.
seen and shot at you you gotta rip your old oh yeah i'm gonna ink i'm gonna start inking i hear a path yeah but he's not shooting unless he's doing my strat to be fair i've only see clara shooting people i don't even know who would have oh wait there's jack okay okay okay i was gonna say i feel like i'm not heard as her other two teammates i'm having such a great time
urchin no no not gonna lie the crypto pick is Like, it is huge.
That is a huge pick.
Yeah, because it's Intel.
But, like, it's crazy, because he was just standing in the open in front of the Seekers and we wouldn't go in invisible mode.
But it's like, it's not that invisible.
This is it.
It's not that invisible.
And then they had a crypto.
Someone's running in a straight line and they throw their drone and you can just see them.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, I'm chasing crypto and he just goes invisible in front of me thinking, like, where did I, where did he go?
And I'm like, bro, what?
Facts, facts, facts.
facts this is so great
we're chilling this is like you know what this is a good relaxation event right after right after street fighter this is a good event to chill guys are these stressing from from all from everything i went through my god i'm actually an arm
I'm about to get hectic pretty soon.
Yeah, cool it down tournament.
I found a new home.
Where are you building next?
Bro, okay, I think you're gonna see that.
That's way too low.
They're definitely gonna see that.
They're not gonna see it.
How would they know?
Imagine you were the first one to get gunned down between the team.
This is like the best strat, I think.
No!
Guys, it's not tree.
Do I need to go find a new home for us?
Technically speaking.
well i know they're like on the other side because i hear the gun shot yeah we need to find a new home we need to find a new home and the mob's coming in together the mob is coming wait i'm gonna leave all right if i get caught i'm put dragging i'm leading if i get caught i'm leading them all to you guys i'm looking over at this in this look there's look at so many of them oh no they have no idea wait these guys are up here wait wait they shot close right yeah they shot close they're to my right i hear it oh yeah oh no oh no no no no no no no no i feel like the popular came in school bro i started to train
seconds though hey do you think we could like queue up onto a rock i'll die for us guys wait is in zone i don't know what rock is in seconds at least the rings i don't know either wait i got an idea this might be crazy i'm gonna try it i wonder what this camera sees right now what about the drone i know it probably looks so do we look like a squad full of killers no it looks tough i can get it to you what if i just do this oh no okay right here right here right here right Right here,
right here, right here, off me.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I was like, what if I just stand here in the bin?
It's like I killed so bad.
No, because Mike went away.
Not to throw this dude's ball again.
No, okay, okay.
I was like, I was like, what if I just hide in this bin?
And then she was right next to me watching me hide in the bin.
No, this is karma for the crimes I've committed.
This is the best spot, maybe ever.
no this is up here no I like I said I what happens to me I know that I know that what I did I think they're right here what I did was so I deserve that yeah we're not last guys we're not last Last guys.
My stats like low key work.
At least we're not 20th.
Oh my god, they have a shield as well.
Oh my god, wait.
They just break this.
I'm coming to you.
Good thing you came.
Oh my god.
Why?
Why would you do this?
They're coming.
He's coming.
Oh my god.
Why would you do this then?
Because I was stuck in the open.
I was dead.
Yeah, that word the whole team's dead.
No, no, I'm good.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
The best thing to do in situations like this is not panic.
Why are they not going Cossack?
A medic, pure fear.
Wait, are they on Cossack?
Okay, I saw Sheila, so I don't know what the other two are playing.
We have to move.
We have to move, bro.
I know, gang.
I know.
Can I get on top of the leaf?
Imagine.
Cauchy has a Kramer.
Move with me, move with me.
He's gonna run into ammo.
Come here, come here, come here.
Be careful this right side.
There was someone here on the right side.
I had to check something real quick.
Okay.
All right.
Oh my god, they have a Kramer, guys.
They have a Kramer, guys.
Be careful.
That's how I died.
Yeah, there it is.
Okay, you guys are moving as a pack, and that's the stupidest thing I've ever seen.
Like...
Listen, hey, death box.
I made it out.
Yeah, but there's a reason why I died.
I've committed some crime.
No.
Come on, run.
Oh, my God.
It's just RNG.
Why are you not healing?
Are you scared?
Yeah, I should be like.
You're so right.
Yeah, I was gonna say why.
I'm in my little hole.
Oh, wait.
What is your little...
You little rampant?
Oh my god My spot's elite my spot is elite my spot is elite.
Oh is he coming back Bro, he's coming back.
Oh I think you gotta leave the portal I'm good Never been better that looked insane on my screen Wait, they're running rampart and rave.
Why are they not running caustic?
Did they like?
Secretly bad.
Bro, are they playing for honor?
Like, is that why they're not doing caustic?
See, you guys know I like to, I abuse the most cheesable characters here.
I ain't about honor, guys.
We're not here but on it.
Don't freaking scare right now, man.
They made a Geneva convention for what I did.
Bro, it is play to win.
I got 32 kills.
If that's not winning, I don't know what is.
Yeah, I didn't sign the convention, by the way.
Yeah.
They're trying to like win the convention.
My skill?
What the fuck is that?
Honor doesn't bring food on the table.
It's all about...
Exactly.
Honor doesn't give you 32.
That's why I'm surprised.
I was like, bro, why is they not playing Gostics?
I play no worries.
I can grieve.
I can grieve these guys.
Should I grieve them?
Do it.
Do it, do it!
Did you do it?
I did, I queued up, I queued them, I queued them.
It's all about you winning.
Oh no, Moose, you're so fucked.
You built a wall!
Bro, you built a wall!
See, everybody wants to play the shields.
Everybody wants to play my shields.
Super idea what happened, right?
Bro, you're theory crafting?
You're Fortniteing right now?
Oh, this is a God spot.
Bro, they have to.
I honestly think they have to re-invite us to be seekers after what we did.
I know you are.
Everybody wants to be with me.
I don't have Q for so long, bro.
I won't have Q for so long.
You gotta live.
You gotta live, Drum, because we need your Q.
Jesus Christ.
OMG.
Bro, you better be getting that.
Wait, do you have... Oh, suck the others off.
I'm so low.
You're so dead.
Oh, eight.
No way.
Aw, eight.
How did people live?
Because they healed.
We did really well, though.
Hey, we did good.
Yeah, we got eight.
We did good.
Yeah.
The red bar was a dumb idea until everybody started hiding behind my shield.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Your theory craft here.
You started cooking.
What if I go Gibby and throw shields?
That is insane.
Insta exploded.
I'm not going to lie.
What if we just do Newcastle?
Oh my god, wait, you're right.
We should go Newcastle.
Okay, but the thing is, we all have to live because we can't run away from people.
No, but if we do Newcastle and you use your alt, is that considered like an alt that does damage?
We should ask that.
We should be like, can we?
We know if we say that, then they'll know.
I'll message Tempo privately.
Can we use Newcastle and use his ult?
Is that damage ability?
All right, Tempo's messaging back.
He's typing.
Oh, no Newcastle because it kills.
Unfortunate.
Oh, apparently people are punching people outside.
of the zone that's what i'm saying that's what i'm saying damn bro what happened what happened in game four everyone was so chill when we were seekers i don't know i don't know maybe we should have been seekers the entire time that's so funny all right no more no more rampart who am i playing not gonna lie crypto is kind of of nuts yeah the intel and the how just the big okay yeah yeah yeah
watch the live leak it was nuts oh wait yeah apparently taxi's team taxi the taxi win that no the taxis team won that round but he also griefs someone but he killed him with a shotgun though no yeah he really killed the phony he's not supposed to have a weapon at all yeah you should i can just go out the door and ask right now yeah god then you should find out right are they dq'd for that they shouldn't get points if they yeah people are actually mad right now that some hiders are mad it wasn't even a punch off the map you know what i mean it was a straight up pick up a gun and that's so funny that's what happened that's crazy oh people that do damage to other people get their round dq'd this includes punished punching and finishing oh they're cooked oh my god we didn't damage anyone guys no no i was just hiding behind my shields that's all i was doing bro i was just queuing around yeah yeah we just chill see we didn't commit any crime this time never not not this time yeah not this
time yes apparently the team so we're seven because the the the team that was yeah we went guys we went up a placement let's go we did it we're seven i think rath might be rath is gonna be sturdy rath is sturdy yeah i was i was considering rath as well heavily oh yeah oh you should make a portal and make it outside of zone like sacrifice your life to portal people outside of zone that should be the strat it's super funny what if you you like put a portal and then it kills the seeker you put portal so far away and it kills the seekers what if I'm being chased what if I'm being chased and I port somebody off the map oh that is that's good somebody literally TP'd them TP'd the seeker off the map you should do that and it was like a two man so hey I don't see where that's not in the rules um hop and see all right Alright.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
We should do that.
Rafe ash portal loot.
Alright.
Oh, apparently, apparently what you threw, because you also threw the ult, it killed a lot of people, including, you killed like some seekers, including caution.
Wait, my, I ult did that?
Yeah, yeah.
They're like, who was it?
I don't even think my ult hit the ground.
ended before like i read the moment i threw my oh really apparently there were two horizon ults at end zone that like sucked the seekers off into the zone i i died like that in one of our games i got pulled off in a zone that was not one of ours at all you're like are you a lad bro there's so many rule how come there's so many rule adjustments after we got off seekers i know no one stood up for us no but because we want to see us winning they don't want to see us dubbing now?
No, I'm just chilling.
It's vibes.
No, because we were really... We were such good seekers that no one wanted to break the rules.
They didn't go next door and complain.
Yeah, when we were secret... They did go next door and complain.
Give me a moment.
It'll be taken care of.
Jojo's face.
Give me a moment, man.
Give me a moment.
They start complaining after we're off secret.
That's so good, for us.
Where's Wraith?
Okay, so why did I go Gibby and give us Dome Dome?
Is that...
Is that good?
I'm gonna be honest.
I don't think so.
I like Mirage.
But you don't think it'll work?
You can play whoever you want, but I don't know if Jimmy Bubble is gonna help us in any way when everybody's up.
I'm trying it.
It's time.
It's time to go invisible.
Oh, apparently, do I have to restart?
I won't DC.
Oh, we gotta rip a scrim in the chat?
Is that what's happening now?
I don't know.
We're gonna rip a scrim.
little restart all right scrims scrims oh scrims there it is i'm gonna have some water i'll be on
it's been pretty chill all right two more games guys two more games and then i'm and then and then we're freed scrims time this has been this has been pretty relaxing not gonna lie
It has been pretty...
I can't believe they wrote the Geneva Convention after what I did.
I'm surprised no one...
I'm surprised no one played Gostic after that.
They must have wrote the Geneva Convention.
I'm like, why wouldn't you play Gostic after the meta I created?
And I didn't sign it.
oh wait someone oh you guys found the clip let me see what wait okay i'm let you guys hear it too it's like really loud oh no it's starting
i'm not even gonna be playing that part that's the best part he doesn't even know
dude that guy's the dude that's the biggest part Dude, I never bought like a...
You think I finished her?
Evan, if you grab that banner, I can rest.
Dude, you can rest me.
That's good.
Yeah, but you died to a bot, Jen.
Can't be that bad.
You died to a bot.
Alright, you know the inevitable highs that occurred at a W is on the horizon.
Okay, wait, I need to adjust.
All right.
Zone prediction time.
Time to test your zone predictions.
I literally have no clue.
It's going to be Lotus for sure.
No, I'm not going to lie.
At the bottom of Galleria is really like a crazy...
Blossom Drive.
Where is that?
Are they close to us?
No, they're on the other side of the map.
Oh, thank God.
I was like, where the heck is Blossom Drive?
Right next to Ocean I have.
God, I always want to tick the nades.
I have found a...
Oh, yeah, I put the screen up.
It makes me want to click...
Grab the nades so bad.
We know what tick everyone knew what I did.
I just can't think of that, bro.
I'm playing a little bit guilty.
I can't lie.
I'm playing a bit guilty right now.
It was my buddy's birthday last night.
Guilty.
Yeah, super guilty right now.
Can't lie.
Oh yeah, I need to deal with this.
I'll do it next time.
It's like, it's so funny, like, how many of you just rip a brew, like, middle of the day lunchtime.
Just go on some just good vibes.
Dude, you could do that in US, bro.
Why is that Canada specific?
People don't do that.
Middle of the work day?
Like, you can rest me.
That's us putting canisters around his body.
Like, no one's raising you.
It was a highlight.
the highlight of the event oh my god i wish the i wish one of the games i actually picked gibby um i wish one of the games i picked gibby guys that would have been so good or bangler that would actually been so good all right check your maps that give me nothing all right yeah yeah um yeah what does that what what does that give us i'm in my mind i thought i was gonna be able to like Yeah,
yeah, like in your mind, it's like, it'll be like, seeker here, and then the arrows pointing at it.
Yeah, it'll be like, did you see it?
It's not really nothing at all.
That was a useless moment.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It'll be like circled and everything.
It's like, did you see it?
I thought we were up.
We have to drop.
Okay, do you not have zone?
Crypto doesn't do zone anymore?
No, just for sure.
worthless no literally i just go invisible though you know just use this what the heck i can go completely invisible man and he can get good res himself one of us dies oh that's true that's true never mind you're not useless exactly you're a good part of the team
okay so maybe we do need are you the only one up in canada right now no i'm in oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just me yes sir i see god his favorites oh no oh you mean like the studio i've been flying in crazy oh whoa yeah i'm at a nokia studio one of them but yeah why didn't they invite why didn't invite you moose you're a seeker i think gino hates me i think that's not true that's not true gino's the goat dude i love gino probably because drums never been to canada no he has been i'm tripping bro he's coming around guys i have the uh mobile respawn beacon so don't let me die so then I can get us up.
I like you should take it from me.
Not all like just like sucking cryptos, you know?
Yeah, okay, but like why would you die?
What if you die?
That's not what I bet.
Okay, true.
You're spinning.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What if you die?
So you know, I don't know, you know this but you go invisible.
Like we can still see you.
I actually might be dead right now.
I might actually be dead right now.
I'm recalling my drone.
How could you be dead?
Oh no, I hear mans and I'm like the middle of the map.
I'm so, yeah, I kind of went over to Lotus, but I'm like super scared that they're here.
I feel like they're not going to be exploring every building.
They don't get any run down right now.
There's no way they're going to be exploring every building.
You know, I'm so confident that they're not going to be exploring every building.
I'm going to stand in this bathroom right now.
I'm sitting in this bathroom.
I'm going straight.
I'm standing in this bathroom, and I'm going to go pee.
I'll be right back.
That's valid.
Honestly, I respect that.
That's, that's, that's the key.
I'll be right back, guys.
You guys go my way.
i think i uh wait where are you listen i might i might i might be the only one that donkeys aren't nice what'd you say yeah nice i said listen i might be the only one in canada right now but i'll be seeing you soon my friend yeah boy i i fucking hope so man i'm trying to see that handsome face again and we can watch you very soon i think i'm coming oh are they on you are they on you no i just fell oh bro i literally am running to you right now i was about to run away so far every time man i was standing on uh one of these staircases because i feel like these staircases like nobody runs up them that's true not everyone takes a zip what if i just wait just marinate tell me i'm just literally marinating in this in in my little corner in my little cubby how can i there we go okay and then prepare yourself there are three other look i'm now i'm invisible in a corner that they would never guess three other squads nearby holy dude i got a nasty headache oh my goodness this trying to rip the
wallow my dog trying to rip the wallow dude i've been i've been drinking water i actually made my uh my hangover concoction i drink it every time i get hung over i literally do like three quarters of a glass of water with like a bunch of salt in it um like half a lemon just all lemon juice and then like a splash of orange juice and it's just all just hydration It tastes terrible.
Like it doesn't taste good.
I would drink that on a Thursday afternoon for the funs of it.
Pro and Medi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, let me check my sound.
Because like every time I unmute myself, my voice alert goes back down.
I was a hurting unit this morning, man.
I can't lie to you, bro.
I was hurting so bad.
All right.
We can just chill.
It wasn't so bad that I had to go pull Treg, but like I was getting close.
I was teetering that line.
That's a bad line to teeter.
That's tough.
Why are you guys grouped up?
by yourself i'm invisible no one will even know that i exist oh that's true they're gonna see moose and then run run at chase moose instead of you when you go invisible i'm literally in like the cut okay little corner invisible dude i'm about to snitch on drums so bad what do you mean dude you snitched on me last game oh you know what oh my god okay no no i got scared and ran to my teammates okay guys you know what this shot at and landed on me and i guess what we all lived because they couldn't do anything because you're a massive shield oh my god Okay guys,
I'll tell you guys one of the strats so like when I was on crypto I use the drone to wrap people out I made the seeker chase after the drone and lead them to like the hiding spots
Charity dog yeah, and I would get the drone and like show it in front of the seeker and then like take him to like the hiding spots of everyone this is this is literally you're you're a fed you're just that's what you are that's right i'm a narc bro i i get to live yeah but guess who's alive the narc for charity am i right for charity i got uh for 25 000 would you snitch on your homie and the overwhelming answer is yes 20 grand is 20 grand bro with the 20 grand i can bail the homie out honestly true i'm associated right now yeah we get 20 grand and i can bail you out it's just that easy you don't even need it look is this the real team hey are you gonna stand Are you gonna do your job?
Yeah, I was your beak one time.
I got you.
I actually hit that one already.
Yeah, I can't even hit it.
I don't know if you know this, but...
Yeah, I think you've been...
You're okay there?
Were you spotted just now?
I think so.
This is such a bad spot.
I gotta figure out how we're gonna get in the zone here.
I mean, there's a walkway right here.
This couldn't have been a worse zone, I think.
Wait, what's the zone?
It's probably the most open spot.
Oh.
So it's just duck hunt for them.
It's literally just gunning us down.
Oh, wait.
Maybe inside there?
Was there a spot?
Wait, oh, they posted the results for us.
Okay, I'm going to check it out.
If I die, it's fine.
They're right here.
That's them.
I see a fucking caustic with a gun.
Terrified.
I'm going to just watch them.
Wait, oh, they're a caustic?
that's crazy my drone went away because i got emp my drone went away because i got emp'd idiot that's stupid
give me a crazy spot in here guys how come i can't get this thing out of my hand guys why is this not thing not getting out of my hand guys what do i press it's been so long
Yeah, never speak to me like that again.
Yeah, my bad.
Oh, there we go.
Hey, man.
How about you never say that to me?
It was three.
I was, like, pressing four.
Wait, I'm going to check the results.
Okay.
I'm going to check.
I'm going to check what the results are.
I'm just looking at what happened.
She's just marinating.
In Galleria.
Hitting the marination.
Wait.
Yeah, I'm just chilling.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
I ain't chilling.
How do I get out of here?
But wait a minute.
Okay, I was like, I may or may not be chilling anymore.
JK, I'm just chilling.
That one's really up and I can like support somebody out the map.
That'd be cool.
That would be pretty cool.
You should do it.
Do it now.
I don't think I can though.
That's the thing.
I hear the shots.
Might be dead.
That may or may not be dead.
I don't know why I'm trying this hard.
Yeah, all right.
All right, I got...
All right, I might be the first one down because I gotta figure out how to get in the zone right now.
All right, guys.
We're saving Private Ryan and it's saving Private Doki.
I'm trying to save myself.
I think they're still on the other side of the map, bro.
High key.
We gotta figure this out.
You standing in front of me, dude?
I'm like paranoid, like right in front of me up here.
I hear gunshots in front of...
There's a pathie, but he's not...
I hear gunshots right in front of me, but I don't know.
Yeah, it's not him.
This is all safe people back here.
Oh, wait, wait.
What is that?
It's a...
All right, this might be the moment where I get gunned down, guys.
Remember me.
Okay, wait.
Look at me.
Listen to me.
This is a bloodhound with a charger.
Remember me, guys.
Chad, I might not make it.
I might not make it.
But I got purple backpack.
The charge rifle.
Oh, God, there's...
There's one right here.
There's people over there.
There's people over there, by the way.
Here's the intel.
I'm sitting over in my little corner, and I'm not gonna...
And I'm not gonna go with it.
Who the fuck is this?
He's not even shooting people right here.
He's just sitting in his...
Alright.
What am I looking at?
I got my little hidey hole.
what is this this can't be one of them this cannot be one of them there's no way this is clara jacking caution what will they do just back oh my gosh almost knocked my water off i mean it literally does look like one and has is acting like one this is very well this don't fucking sucks not gonna lie i'm stuck here too i gotta move i don't understand what the hood is bloodhound is this somebody like being he's just shooting the ground what am i at what is there there's an ai in this game i don't know they added ai there's an ai in there just tell gino that real quick there's like i don't know who that is but i don't know what the frick is that hey guys i know you had me on the lobby can you can y'all what is it i don't know who this is or what's going on right here it'll confuse the seekers it's gonna confuse them because they'll be like what is he doing and they'll feel bad for killing him i'm dipping i'm
Oh, you're going out.
Oh, there's a lot of gunshots.
There's a lot of gunshots, by the way.
I'm going to get barely in over here and just...
Oh, it's getting a little scary.
It's getting a little spooky scary.
I think this is...
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
No!
Wait, he's retreating over here!
Alright, so, um...
It got very scary.
Oh, they're so close to me.
I'm in Viz.
I'm in Viz right now.
I'm just watching with a drone.
Can you get her bed?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Grab it.
Wait, do we have Rizzes?
Anyway?
Oh, guys, maybe...
They don't shoot the drones, by the way.
You're fine.
They don't shoot drones.
Maybe I should have given you the mobile Rizz beacon.
You know, it's all good because I can't even get it in Viz right now because if I get it in Viz, I'm just dead.
You think they'll know?
Do you have if you have a wait steal someone someone steal someone's mobile res beacon.
Yeah, I know I'm trying to see someone put one Yeah, yeah, yeah, they this team is so scary brother.
So close to me Steal it.
Why would you do that?
Why would you grief me wait no if they punch wait if they punch That's considered a DQ Apparently yeah people that do damage to other people will get their round DQ'd who did that?
Who did that?
You're DQ'd for that, for sure.
DQ'd right there.
Whoever that horizon was, Chad.
Yeah, whoever that, Chad, tell us.
I got the tempo DMs open.
Let's get them out of here.
Oh, they do that.
It's such insane.
I lived, though.
I lived, I lived, I lived.
Oh, I'm scared though.
I got to get in the zone, actually.
And they're close.
Yeah, this is not my, this is not the time.
I got to go right now.
I'm back.
Yeah, you're, you're like, ready to die.
This is like my only opportunity for anything.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, um, Moose, you might be the last survivor.
Yeah, Moose, it's all up to you.
All right, no, who was that guy?
Let's EQ them as well.
We're going down with...
EQ!
We'll take them down with us.
Dumb.
They may know I'm here.
They're not going to fin me.
They're not going to fin me, Moose.
Yeah, Moose, do the res.
Oh, no, they're finning.
They're finning.
That's just, that's a, that feels like a crime.
It's okay, Moose, I believe in you.
Thanks, guys.
I'll do my best.
If anything, you should find the squad and just, like, group up with them, because the seekers have to pick one, and you gotta take your chances.
I have a play, and it might work.
They're active over there, and I am in right on this bush.
And if nobody punches me, which has happened to Drum.
Twice!
I should be...
be good here i should be good punch bro that's so cringe
that is pretty cringe like why did he do that i want to know who it is so bad and i want to know if i'm right on my assumption okay how would he know it was you though how would he i'm gonna do some investigative reporting investigating journalism right here Live journalism happening right now.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
With all you guys grouped up, I like my odds.
They have to pick one person to shoot, and it won't be you.
Exactly.
I like my odds.
I like it, dude.
I'm sitting pretty right now.
I'm a believer.
Yeah, I'm a believer.
You got this easy, bro.
Bro, look at that.
If anything, you got a meat shield right there, too, in front of you.
You gotta pick one per- Wait the fuck, he got the res?
He has, I heard someone get a res.
I heard that do.
I think it's bad that we have, you only have blue armor, because that's a one headshot right there.
Yeah.
You're in view of the enemy.
Oh no, which one?
Only 10 seconds left.
Oh, there's a lot of guns.
The zone is close.
Oh, it's end zone.
It's all about surviving, Mel.
You might need a heal soon.
We're just slowly.
The slow crawl.
The very, very slow crawl.
This is the true strat.
My strat is I got to set a port.
Probably I like the 15.
second mark or actually maybe I'll start loading it up at the 45 second mark wait where are you putting the port right at the right at the end zone oh so it'll take people outside the zone is that the strat oh my god you're absolutely wild for that look at that back side corner oh yeah you can just get in that room a hot minute oh my god
Around the world around the world.
Oh, it's a caustic.
Oh, they someone decided to leave a convention Oh my god, they know what their plan is It's gonna go away like in like 30.
Yeah, well, it's 20 seconds left though.
I didn't realize I can't see it because all I see is Jerome's detected on it Bro, this is actual screen clip.
Yes.
You're chilling.
You're chilling What am I looking at?
Wait, when does the portal end though?
He has like probably like 15 more seconds on it.
A lot of people are.
A lot of people are doing what you did.
Oh my god, they're literally on you.
Oh my god.
There's no one more.
You're not one more portal!
That's crucial time.
And you have your cue back.
You should have your cue back very soon.
way to get them you might have to heal oh i don't think you're getting any heels out oh no you're you're dead no no no no oh we got four we got four four four for skin oh my god no no if you if you would have kept your port and watch my exercise you win that 100 yeah yeah yeah yeah dude i literally all I had on my screen I couldn't see the distance of my port because all I had was drone scan by the crypto drone yeah I literally could not see the distance I had left caution and Clara and Jack are not even the winners they didn't even win who died oh yeah apparently I asked tempo he's like oh yeah we can see the damage numbers so like anyone that has done any damage on the Tyler's team will get like points like taken away if I destroy a drone with my knife does that count as damage surely not right did you destroy a drone with a knife yeah I did oh no we were gonna oh it was like no no it wasn't any damage done to anybody oh it doesn't count as damage okay I was gonna say Tim was like I
was like oh my god did I self-report ourselves no we're good no we're
that'd be crazy i just self-reported hard that's so funny oh apparently we're people oh there's people punching and using oh people are heavy punching i see right so how do you see like the how do you see the overall like results yeah it's uh tempo posted in the general chat or the Nokia chat.
But that was like games one to three.
No, but they have.
We're currently seventh overall.
Oh, I don't need to see it.
I'm tripping.
It's games four to six.
Timbo literally typed in the game chat.
You know we can see individual player damage numbers, right?
You're caught, kid.
And I literally got that.
I got damage done.
I got hit for like 15 or whatever it is.
And you can melee someone.
that's so funny all right last game is last game lg i can't believe we're setting seven overall right now who's first uh 100 thieves oh oh my super ready i don't know wait is did they put two yeah yeah they added two games together yeah because 100 thieves got second i think i think we go with that comp the horizon oh yeah oh valc yeah i mean i'll just i could rip whoever it doesn't matter uh don't you pick first go oh my god i don't know i don't okay uh horizon horizon i don't know how i'll play valk i've never touched valk in my life okay i mean defaulty controller moment but uh it might be tetanop on the velk sir yeah of course you wait do you want velk no not oh yeah no that's not at all oh that's fine bro yeah i'll be i'll be fine on velk yeah i'll be good bro but you were you were cooking on rave though true he was yeah no we should no you should say rave you're cooking out rave i'm gonna throw on velk i'm not gonna okay i'll throw on velk i'll throw on valve because you were
cooking on horizon so i'll i'll be the weakest thing big zoom it's just because it's like uh where's the back oh there it is Oh wait, what am I?
Yeah, horizon, horizon.
I'll be the weakest thing.
Wait, so you want to go?
So you want to go Valk?
Yeah, yeah, I go Valk.
Go right, go right, go right, go right.
Yeah, my bad.
I was looking at the overall scores.
I think so.
How does it say that we're overall in seventh though?
Because I'm looking at it.
We have a score of 213.
And we're in first on my screen.
Wait, what?
No, you're tripping.
you're looking at game one to three am i looking at game one to three when we're killing everyone i'm down to stop right there i'm down what can we jump mad early whatever here pals plot in the landon's one of my specialities all right last game everyone roll it like yeah i was like why did you think we're 103 points We're gonna get first like second obviously third whatever in this game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah Obviously that's how it usually goes Coming in hot I'm surprised they haven't oh my gosh.
I can't believe they didn't play Gibby as well if they went Cossack and Gibby.
Oh, man That team would have been cooking and with kills
You're trying to be every single med I've ever seen in the history of all time surely no one's gonna punch me this game surely i think i think tempo has uh has told them not to because he's like i can see all the damage that you guys do yeah they're griefing all right wait is this gonna be like a base driver zone maybe or bonsai base driver or bonsai where is that oh
like we definitely might need to try and get purple armor purple armor might be a pretty good about now you can hit uh you can hit beacon oh where's the beacon beacon oh there's the next zone okay here okay i'll get the zone do you guys need bats i have four i got four all right i haven't there were oasis god where is this beacon should be telling you this oh god i had to take the jump pad i don't wanna whoops i do not want that name we i've not been in this part of the map before
guys did you see them did you see this oh yeah yeah yeah yeah did you see it uh this guy right
yeah there's like a red circle around them they landed where was it oasis oasis yeah i'm gonna go for the other beacon there's no way they're looking out of zone anyway i feel that that'd be crazy i'm gonna scan that and i'm gonna get shot at i don't believe i'm a believer don't speak that into i was like there's no way they're that freaky you know oh my god we can hide in trees on this map you can you can't hide in trees when we were seeking i found somebody i've done floating hiding in a bush like straight up nice that was insane how do i get over in this in this house oh my god this valk knows how to do the beacon scan oh i'm for sure pouring somebody off the map oh you should do it i'm getting don't be a pussy if i'm getting chased by by them i'm absolutely pouring them off the map
oh my buddy valve okay here's another evo charge everyone huge i'll go honestly i'm going here for now all right i'm heading to the next one can we get on to like the top of bonsai up here though
Is that a thing still?
Well, they probably have that timer, though, right?
I want to...
Yeah.
Okay, there might be a possibility that I get shot while doing this next one.
Wait.
Why does he have a gun?
That guy has a...
Oh, wait.
No, it's his heirloom.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
It looks like he had a gun, you know.
You're a tripping, fool.
Hey, man.
I don't want to die, man.
Alright, going for the next scan.
Guys, we're...
Why are you guys contributing to the armor upgrades, guys?
I don't see anything.
I can't do anything, honestly.
Honestly, this is like group effort.
Why am I doing all the scans for us?
I did hit the juicer.
I did hit the person.
Check your map.
Wait.
Isn't there like a...
No.
Bro, there's so many people.
Alright, there is...
I have another one at Bonzai.
Oh my gosh, nobody He trusts anyone anywhere.
This is my...
This is my spot.
That's not conspicuous at all.
I'm heading for the another beacon.
This is my nether.
He is painting in assholes.
How do we get purple armor, guys?
I don't think...
Yeah, we have to go, like, out here to get this, and I'm scared of this direction.
Oh, maybe.
That'll be fine.
He'll be healthy.
You know what?
I'll do it for the team.
I'm grabbing it for us.
There's a real MVP this whole time.
I'm gonna cave up.
Alright guys.
I'm gonna go head to that.
Where is it?
Wait, where's the evil harvester?
Where even is it?
I feel like I'm definitely not doing a good job hiding here.
I feel like you can definitely see me.
Wait, where?
I don't see any evil harvester.
Oh, it's here.
Okay, I'm gonna go over there, grab it.
it and die for us so you guys can have purple armor you can just alt to it no i feel like i feel like alt to it i i'm gonna use it to run away surely don't shoot me while i'm trying to alt right wings up all right i'm gonna head over i'm gonna be a hero be safe have fun be headed over to i'm heading over to the evo dash don't worry guys i'm there i'm there i'm there oh wait you're gonna If you're gonna go,
I'm not going.
I just said, uh, yeah, I just said a thing.
So yeah, yeah, I was gonna say, I ain't going.
You're gonna go.
All right, I don't need to be here.
You can probably tell that I'm hiding in.
I'm gonna pick this tree.
Wait, this is in the zone.
Is it?
Oh, wait, it is.
Yeah, we're in zone.
In the ring.
Can't help you if you're like, I'm like, am I obvious?
Doki, Doki, keep it a buck with me.
Am I obvious right here?
No, you're so safe.
All right, all right.
I trust you.
You would never ever ever ever question that whenever I lied to you literally never not yeah, exactly.
We just met and I've never lied to you in my life
Exactly, you know what I'm a sad way.
I feel like people will think I'm rising Don't be so fed dude.
Don't trust her I'll go I'll go buy a ticket What's your what's your the last three digits of your social security number?
too like oh my god what's your blood type yeah what's your um what school what's the first school you went to uh what's your pet's first name yeah yeah yeah remember to fill in your security questions don't worry i'm i'm the security and those little numbers in the back of your credit card go ahead yeah yeah yeah i'm like to capture the system i got you i honestly can't really see anything through this tree so hopefully it's good can you make that yeah you're chilling You're chilling.
You're chilling.
No tree strats, bro.
I can't even find a tree to climb up on.
Wait, it's kind of- it's kind of sturdy?
Are we kind of sturdy right now?
I got- I got a thing.
I kind of- wait, I have a plan.
I have a plan too.
Wait, do you- do you remember the climb up?
We'll climb up.
Wait, where?
Oh!
Damn it, he- I was gonna- I was gonna hang off the ledge there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, do it.
Just me though, you egg me up.
Don't worry.
He's gonna be my meat shield.
Wait, I almost did it.
Hold on.
No.
Car?
Guys, what happened to your stride?
You're not allowed to use the car.
They're not allowed to use strides.
It's the bloodhound that was shooting last game!
Bro, who is this bloodhound?
He's wild.
I think they're like, they're not in it to win anymore.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I gotta get like the perfect climb up here.
So you don't get damage you don't take that get damage from punching a drone right too far.
I think I'm still seen really easily Cooked might move.
Yeah, yeah, you are.
Yeah, you are you are.
Yeah, you got to be you got to be way more to no He's totally safe.
I think he's safe.
No, I let go too soon.
Yeah, I got it.
I'm here.
I did it.
I did it before.
Hold on.
Oh, you got it All right, let's see where zone's coming.
I got it.
Oh, nice let's go dude i might be a little bit i might be a little bit too bobby i might be i might be on the open no no i think you're good you're in a good spot i think yeah yeah i believe i believe i see please please let us get zone pulled bro this is the most elite hiding spot of all time wait are you just kidding me by the ledge wait that is so smart how do you do that he says like time it right it's kind of hard look you i think that i'm in a bad spot i think Well,
I'm gonna try that.
I think I'm good, but like, to the right, there's such a big opening.
Like, I might be- Try it.
You can try getting closer to me.
We did get a zone.
I don't think I can get closer to you, bro.
Wait, I'm gonna try doing it too.
I'm gonna climb to you as well.
You think if I do it, I'll fall off the ledge?
We're all- all of us are doing it now.
This is so funny.
Wings up.
How did you guys do that?
What?
It's low-key hard.
Like, you know, there's a whole W key to it.
Oh my god, they're all here now.
Guys, I can't do it.
Oh, no, everyone wants to do it.
Setting us up.
They're all sick.
Yeah, we're getting muddled down for sure.
I can't do it on the others.
I can do it on the safe side.
Bro, I don't know how you guys are doing it.
Yeah, they don't want to cheat.
Get called out.
Are they trying?
I hear some of the things around me, but like, I don't know what's happening.
It's just us.
I want to let you know, brother, like, one horizon tag to, like, get up here and, like, it's over for me.
Oh, my God.
She's right beside me.
She's right beside me, isn't he?
She's right.
I'm not moving.
How would she know, Moose?
How would she know?
She's going to think she cleared this whole area, move on, and we're good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No!
it was not a yeah yeah moment it was not a yeah yeah moment look i led her away from you guys she's now on low ground i did it for us i yeah yeah yeah yeah i led her away from us i did it go yeah yeah i did it for the team i did it for the team i made a drop down no way they know we're here there's no way they know there's no way they know okay someone said single gray we're not gonna go crazy we're getting collided immediately shut up
we gotta wait we gotta wait for them to wait for like a whole minute i think you should tp like tps somewhere safe i'm just gonna take it you want me to do it now i can do it now no no wait like a whole minute bro like wait as much time as possible yeah i believe i believe and like it's like the other side of the zone if you can because like ports so far you know oh my god she's only been on low ground since she chased me you're welcome you're gonna chase the port and not know like you know what i mean and we'll be chilling i think we're just safe to walk in i mean listen i gave you the option for the plan you can either do it or not whatever happens we're going forward that's all i know i mean you guys can split the plan here's the thing i like your plan i think it's a good plan but it sucks so The stupidest plans can tend to work because they don't expect you to do the stupidest thing.
I'm saying, bro.
Yeah, exactly.
Or throw the whole game to Kraft Doki, like real ones.
One's right underneath us.
Yeah, 20 seconds, dude.
We gotta go.
Oh, they're like...
Climb this, climb this, climb this, climb this now, climb this now.
All I'm saying is you guys should have done the plan earlier.
You hesitated.
I believe 10 seconds to the ring it's close they can't come up here you hesitate I will scream drop at the top of my lungs Oh, I'm in danger.
Just letting you know Wait, but do you have portals for the last?
Do you have portal for the last one?
You're fine.
I'll have it.
I'll have it back soon Okay, because I was gonna say Maybe you should grab some alt I'm not in zone.
I'm not in freaking zone.
Come to me.
Come to me Oh, trust me, I'm coming.
Oh, they're so close.
They're so close.
I know there.
It's a wraith.
That's a wraith.
That's not them.
I just do a bait queue.
All right.
When you see a stack of people, remember to throw a queue on them.
I can't.
I need to get DCB for that little key.
No, they can't because it's not damage.
It's not damage.
It works.
You got to fend for yourself.
This is so dumb.
This is the worst hiding spot of all time.
You know what to do with you, too.
This zone is so bad, too.
Also, you might need a heal.
Oh, they're right there?
I'm right there.
I'm right here.
I'm here.
Oh, there's the guy to your right as well.
I'm getting Doki back in.
Yes.
Oh, yes!
Yes!
Ha ha, where did you pick up my banner?
I'm gonna get gunned down.
I grafted it.
Look at this avatar here.
Look at my ping.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God, oh, my God.
Bad spot, bad spot, bad spot, bad spot.
For sure.
I have a replay.
Can I go?
Ducky, can you sit out on the wall?
Can you sit on this wall?
I'm trying.
I'm trying so hard.
No, I can't, I can't, I can't, I couldn't!
Ducky's in the other side of us now.
They're so close to me, bro.
Can I take that port moves or no?
You can, but it's not in zone.
It's fine, but you still live for now.
And there might be one above us.
As long as Doki's up, we're good.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm so chilling.
I'm never not chilled.
I don't feel chilling, guys.
If there's anybody that's not chilling, it's me are you don't you fly fly up to the top of that fly to the top of this where's that sit crouch behind that dude use them as a meat shield oh my god I can't I can't not now not yet not yet that's a rampart about me that's a rampart about me are we dead no you're so healthy you're so healthy jump come sit on the fridge with me come sit on the fridge come sit on the fridge I'm gonna get this for him.
Oh my god, they're right next to me.
Okay.
Oh my god, I messed up.
Oh my god.
I'm like, everybody know that my palms are sweaty.
And my knees weak and my arms are in fact heavy.
Hello everyone.
Hey, I'm in- I'm up up.
I'm up up up it.
I'm up it now.
Wait, Ducky's in the lead spot.
Yeah, yeah, I'm with the gang.
I'm with the crew.
i'm gonna heal up there i don't care we i'm gonna heal up there so that we all get shot everyone's here we're gonna get swung i'm getting out of here i'm getting out of here drama have an elite plan but it involves you throwing your cue okay okay i need you to throw your cue onto me like right now maybe not right now maybe not right now maybe not right now right now right now not right now not right now what i'm gonna do is I'm going to start the portal at the top of your thing in like in zone like oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god yeah bad bad bad bad bad like right right I believe I need you to throw it exactly right there I'm gonna go up the queue right here I'm gonna pop my port and I'm gonna start building it up win win holy shit this plan is so confusing oh this is bad this is so bad everything about this is bad this is a very confusing plan I'm very confused oh moose you are gonna make sure What's right there?
What the frick?
Oh, I fucked up.
I messed up.
I'm in the zone.
Oh, no, please.
Oh, I'm going to die.
I'm going to die.
Yeah, I messed up.
I died to the right.
I was like, don't worry.
I can literally do this.
What did we do?
I've never run out of ammo.
I didn't realize the zone goes so fast.
I was trying to stall like my oh dang it guys oh so sad I had such a good plan too but then it was like I was like oh maybe not now because I don't want to have to hold my my port for that long you had the plan and then if you got the one HP wait what was the plan he just stood over top of me yeah he just sat there I was trying to hug the wall what even was the plan you guys were crafting so basically what we did last game where i start my portal at the very top yeah of uh of a horizon queue and then i finish it at the bottom so basically you just keep dropping from one portal to another infinitely oh so like how did it fail well i got shot as soon as i as soon as i read the
wanted to do yeah that that seems right that seems right just getting shot right after
it's okay we both met we all of us messed up i was in my alt form and i might have let the zone kill me while i was alting because i mistimed the zone
that's what oh my wait everyone's doing it oh my god you theory crafted that not everyone's doing
up who won i don't know who won uh we'll find out soon we'll find out
oh 100 okay they go out first they won for charity yeah they got it yeah they got the charity dang all right so what was the plan now we have to stick around and like watch the rest yeah they want us to stick around for a minute home let me oh because there's like a special raffle or something that they're like they spin the wheel and someone gets some special prize
yeah hundreds he's got uh wait the seekers died at seventh place was that
wait what were they doing how were they seven i don't know
i do not know but i shall stick around i guess oh wait wait did they say like we have to keep the stream on okay wait let's yeah what's who's streaming you guys are you going to i have no idea they actually said we have the all of us at the sticker okay wait let me see i'm looking at the thing i'm doing a randy stream uh make sure you tune into the main since they were doing a special raffle for you oh the mainstream okay i know randy is casting vicky's casting that was fun though that was very fun wait who's the main caster it's like it was like me they're like go to the main caster stream like which one is that i am not too sure dokey i'm not too sure gd slapshot underscore gd because like i don't know where it is i put it in link the mainstream that's fun yeah i think Secret was so fun.
I think I enjoyed the most playing Siki.
Don't, they're like, don't, they're like, don't forget to join the mainstream, but which is the mainstream?
I have a feeling it's probably, it's probably Jino?
Yeah, I'm at Jino's stream.
I'm at Jino's stream right now.
Is that the mainstream?
Or you can go either go Slapshot underscore GD or you can go to Rain Day or you can go to Vicky Kitty.
Oh, so there's.
their own casting streams yeah they're all casting from their own oh okay are you sure that's the main one it'll same info between all three so there's that wait oh it's like creator pro women and I'm like wait why isn't create women part of the category like in its own category
Moose with the 78 kill dub damn what I do and drum with 58 you got first you got the Charity.
You got the charity.
You got charity.
You're so lucky.
You're the first.
I missed it, bro.
For the seekers.
Yeah, yeah.
You're so lucky I didn't go Cossack for three games in a row.
Yeah, I am lucky I didn't go Cossack in game one.
I can't believe I just won the...
Wait, what?
Yeah, you won first.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
It's all because Doki gave it to me pretty much.
That's basically what it is.
I should just be thanking Doki.
Yeah, I could have...
If I really wanted to, I could have went Cossack three games in a row.
look i'm just i'm so humble
i'm still trying to find the stream guys i'm still trying to find the stream
oh i found it i found it
wait i'll let you guys place so arm down on that you guys hear this multiple times so there's a bunch of adjustments we have to make for each game Since by default, it's set to give 25 points to whoever ended this session because we assumed first would always be the seekers there.
All right, how about now?
Is that better?
100 thieves had such a massive lead.
From the first three games.
Bro, goat rats.
They just needed to maintain a decent placement across the last three games, which is what they did.
And then they kept their first place spot.
So with that, I have three little messages to say before we...
we part ways tonight.
The first one is, obviously, you know, I, if you go to, if you went to where I suggest you go to thenokia.com now slash Apex over Wi-Fi that all the casters were using, all the players, the draw will be done on Monday.
So for the controllers, that will be done on Monday, and it will be posted and we'll announce it accordingly.
So super excited about that.
The second announcement is we actually have for all of the people that participate, all the 60 players, That's me.
Special prices.
That's me.
I have two Samsung Galaxy 7 Z Fold phones.
Top of the line.
We get phones, guys!
What?
So what I'm gonna do...
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
One person gets the phone.
One person.
That's bullshit.
It's a giveaway.
I missed it.
What happened?
I have the number generator.
It's on screen.
So I'm gonna keep the number generator.
Okay.
Okay, yeah.
And the lobby get a phone.
tell me you know on this spreadsheet which would that well surely it's got to be first one it has to be me right it just has to be right yeah all i'm saying is that it has to be me players um that's just that i contribute to so much content it should be me and that's just straight up by alphabetical order um since okay since google will be doing the randomizing part anyway correct so the first the winner of the first z phone is 46 wait who's that who's that 46 be rhino what is it rhino rhino line rhino my man doug he's like oh wait how many phones are you giving away let's go number 22 22 22 puts us at oh jesus christ i don't think we're i think we're like one two and three I don't know his point.
Is it Jen Burn?
Jen Burn gets it!
No shot!
He's a millionaire!
Dude!
Did this probably get a piece of yet?
Reroll!
He won!
Maybe that'll help.
Yeah, so congratulations to our two winners.
There's only two winners and Jen's one of them.
Yeah, thank you for calling on to helping us with that.
Okay, it's been a long day.
Everybody's tired.
I have one last special.
So first a little disclaimer, as with anything in life, you know, barring any unforeseen logistics issues or legal issues or anything like that.
I'm happy to announce that Nokia is planning to be at Atlanta in Sapporo.
So we will be bringing back our 1v1 boot for chance in Sapporo again.
So that's going to be amazing.
Super excited.
Come on now.
You know, 50,000 people.
will be attending this year cool but here's the other part of the little secret we i am doing this live and officially extending an invitation to six people that participate in their event today to come and be brand ambassadors at the event with no key oh it should be us because we were the seekers well drum roll again caution whoa drum bum wow we the people girl oh and envy those will be our six grand ambassadors let's go whoa i know him i know drum your boy going to japan in january wait did you know help facilitate meet people play against oh wait did you actually just found out now this is the official announcement of it like it was nothing was official i did not know you did not know this is the official we're going to japan bro
time on your day out of your lives to support a charity event like this and this is a way for us to give back a little bit you know to that so for all six uh content creators oh because you guys have to do the one-me-one stuff right um yeah we'll be we'll be yeah we did it in uh again thank you so much yeah to our oh so yeah that's like because like you guys have to meet in person to do the it in a couple months it was a good time thanks for talking i'm having so much fun by the way i have envy in my chat we're literally like freaking out we're here geeking right now do you know you are amazing yeah gina would be remiss not to uh i know you did a lot of logistics there but um i'd love for you to leave us on a final tone i'll get uh i'll get vicky and dia as we kind of close out after that but just for you this has been a big event bringing everyone together you got everyone gathered here watching no one's playing anymore all the creators maybe the six are going to japan guys because
they're doing the 1v1s and i ain't doing 1v1s guys i'm committing mental warfare not physical warfare like the only thing i love you i'm here to break the mind not shoot the gun but i do have my other japan trip the only thing i don't know i'm going to world next year i don't know if and when you make a choice to pick a broadband service right your your espf that's me i'm on the screen you ask them are you using nokia equipment and the reason i say that is believe it or not that makes it back to us and we we don't sell anything oh yeah yeah i got the what i'm trying to do is they gave us a controller too i should actually forgot to show it to you guys i'm sliding up out of here y'all ggs that was so fun yeah ggs i had a great time
It was nice to meet you too.
It was so nice to gaslight both of you too because you didn't know who I was.
Yeah, no, that was fucked up.
I'll take it with me forever that Doki is in fact the dickhead.
I'm basically the Fed.
I'm not more of it.
Not basically, you are.
I am the Fed.
You are all the Fed.
That's great.
It was a pleasure.
It was nice.
GG's, yes.
GG's.
Great time.
Congrats on Japan.
Bye-bye.
Thank you so much.
That was fun.
That was so fun, guys.
It was a nice chill session Right after the stressful Street Fighter tournament I love that they didn't know who I was so I could like say the most Just mess with them because they didn't know they don't know who I was so I could mess with them a little bit Yeah,
yeah the gas lighting and the war crimes.
It was pretty Perfect, perfect in the perfect, I was in the perfect world where they don't know who, who I was.
Anyways, thank you all for coming.
She's horrible.
All right, that's my old she.
Thank you, Tempo, and Nokia for inviting me.
I have, so I'm giving me a secret, one of the seekers.
I felt like I created so much content.
a secret um thank you everyone for watching i hope you guys had a great time watching me i do have a sponsor next week on wednesday uh for my schedule okay the schedule is that i won't be streaming on sunday or monday i can't say what the sponsor is but i do have a sponsor on wednesday um as always i'll announce whenever they announce the sponsor i'll announce it as well um i don't know when they're gonna announce what the sponsor is uh but you guys might know sort of know every time i say that you guys sort of know what sponsor it is because there's only one game that sponsors me that would be like uh don't put on schedule until it's announced you know
um um other than that uh we also have we're gonna finish batman next week as well uh we're gonna finish batman next week and that's the whole plan so far so i don't know what else is there uh but thank you all for watching um cannot confirm nor deny what the sponsor is sunday monday i'm taking the day off and also working on soundproofing so we can have our 5 a.m dgen streams again um and i don't know what's on tuesday like i said these are all the things that i i know i want to play any collabs i don't know i've been like so stressed out this week this week was so stressful honestly it's one of the most stressful weeks uh i was so like because i didn't put the waiting room about for this tournament i didn't really announce anything for this tournament in terms of like you know the waiting room everything and you know then i was like a little um all over place because i was like the thumbnail was like a bit like uh you know people think it was a normal apex tournament so i had to like
be like oh he be can you please fix the thumbnail before the stream and then like she sent in all the edits and stuff like two minutes before i suppose uh before before 11 a.m and i felt so bad because you know i was sleeping so i couldn't give her this i forgot to give her the specific details that was on me um oh my god oh i knew i forgot something i forgot oh my god okay i've i forgot to put the nokia image overlay on the screen oh no oh no okay i'm gonna apologize to tempo i was supposed to have the nokia image on the screen i got everything i even got the command i even got the command in and put it in the title oh i do i forgot oh my god i'll put it in now i'll put it in now guys uh i'm gonna give me a sec so at least it was on the screen you know i'll put it on now oh my god i knew i forgot to do something oh my god okay give me a sec give me a sec do it now i was like
It was there the entire...
Guys, it was there the entire time, guys.
It was there the entire time.
I swear to God, it was there the entire time.
Yeah,
also, to apologize, here you go.
look at that right here check out Nokia um I oh my gosh it was there the entire time guys we all remember it was there the entire time it was just really low exactly exactly it's very very low opacity and everything um but yeah singing again everyone uh yeah guys we all saw it right we all saw the image being there the entire time we all saw it we all saw it hey guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that blood flowing and you still for me head to bed because you deserve it thank you all for watching this was the most chaotic week so far um it was very tiring and everything but i'm glad i'm glad we made it through next week was gonna is gonna be more show i don't know next week if there's any collabs next week because like it was a full week of interaction with people and my social battery is pretty dead right now um so so i don't know anyway guys bye everyone bye bye bye buy my merch by the way there is a controller merch um out right now um
if we maybe give them enough orders we might be able to you know maybe there's possibility to do other types of controllers you know ha ha wink wink so it'll be great if you guys can you know uh check out the controller anyway guys see ya bye